Hello Ladies and gentlemen and,
and people that prefer to be genderless.
If you one of those,
this is a new era,
we have to be super sensitive to
everybody. That's what queer is, right?
You're like, I'm this,
I'm that. Um, it um,
this episode is brought
to you by Ting Tang is a,
I have a new tank phone by the way.
I just got it.
This is the official cell phone of this
podcast and I got the Samsung Galaxy s
five, which has a heart rate monitor
built in young Jamie right there.
You put your finger,
it tells you shit about yourself,
like you're fat or you're not fat or
you're fucking awesome or you're going to
die. And uh, tracks
all sorts. It's like a,
there's a fit program that comes with it.
It's dope.
I am officially a phone whore though.
My third phone this year that makes
me a phone horse and you know, how's,
it's only only August, but I
love technology. I love it.
Um,
what Ting is,
is a mobile service that
uses the sprint backbone.
And what they do is they use
sprint but you don't go by sprints.
Rules go by tings, rules and tings.
Rules are incredibly beneficial to you.
A 98% of people would save money
with tank and they have no contracts,
no early termination fees,
no nothing,
no bullshit. And you also don't
pay a flat rate per month,
which I like because most of the time
you don't use all your minutes and it's
kind of ridiculous. You know,
you pay for 120 minutes,
use 90 what happens is other 30 minutes,
nothing that they're gone there in the
ether next month, new cycle, 120 minutes.
Again,
Tim doesn't do it that way with Tang,
you pay for what you use and I think
it's the smartest way to do it.
They have incredibly high rates ratings
rather if you look online as far as like
people that use ting, how much they
loved them, they're like they're,
they're applauded left and right and
it's because the ethics of the company to
extremely intelligent group of people
that put together this plan. They said,
you know what?
We can,
you could still make a lot of
money without fucking people over.
And that's what they decided to do.
A $21 is the average monthly
bill per device for 10 customers.
It's pretty sweet.
Um,
and they have all of the latest
and greatest android phones.
Like this one that I have right here,
which is the Samsung Galaxy s five,
which is, it's pretty dope. It's
beautiful big five inch screen.
It's awesome for going online and shit,
but they have all the android phones and
when you buy them from Tang, you own it.
It's yours.
That's it.
If you're a cheapskate and you
don't like spend a lot of money,
you can get an iPhone four
for just 95 bucks. Um,
if you want to get the top of the line,
you can get an iPhone five for only 250
bucks. And when you pay that 250 bucks,
you actually own it.
When you buy a phone from most companies
and say if you buy a phone and the
phone says to 99, it's not really two 99
what it is, it's probably like 600 bucks,
but you pay off the other 300 bucks
over time. So if you try to cancel,
they hit you with this fee.
So what the fee is is every month they
just tack on a little of the price of the
phone to your bill. That's kind
of stupid in my id, in my eyes.
It's kind of ridiculous.
You don't need to do it that way.
And if you do it through Tang, you
just buy the phone, you own it,
cancel when you want and
then be done with it. Uh,
and if you go to rogan.ting.com you
can save 25 bucks off of any of these
beautiful devices. Uh, it's an
ethical company in awesome company.
They have a great service.
The sprint backbone is a
fantastic network and you know,
it's not like you're using a
mom and pop cell phone company.
You're using one of the major providers,
you're using the same service that you
get with sprint, but with tings, rules.
I love it.
And again,
it is the official cell phone of this
podcast and got one right in front of me,
rogan.ting.com and that is
the only commercial today.
How about them apples, bitches,
Abby Martins here. Why fuck around.
Cue The music.
Young Jamie,
the Joe Rogan experience by day
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
So
Mrs Rogan sends me this video,
she goes, uh, have you seen this?
Like what do you think about Gaza?
What's going on with Gaza? What did,
what do you,
what is your take on this?
And she sends me a
video of you and I said,
that's my friend Abby Martin who
took this very controversial stance.
And um, it's, it's a tricky
situation, isn't it? Like Gaza is,
first of all,
it's sad and depressing and disgusting,
but it's also very tricky because
there's all this weird biases that,
that are going on left and right.
You know,
there's the United States has this weird
bias where they're criticizing Israel
and Israel is like, Hey, fuck heads,
didn't you guys bomb the shit out
of Iraq and you bomb the shit out of
Afghanistan. You guys are talking
about innocent civilians being killed.
Like what about you?
And then there's also people on the
Palestinian side that think it's just
fucking horrendous what Israel is doing.
And then there's people on the
Israeli side that thank Hamas,
just signed the peace treaty and stop
training suicide bombers. You know,
there's an,
in my opinion,
when I look at it and I am obviously
not qualified to be some sort of a
political analysts, but when I look at
it, I try to look at it objectively.
The whole thing looks
like a just a disaster,
like a huge humanitarian disaster.
I think it's one of the largest
humanitarian issues in the world today.
And I think that we're going to
look back in 50 years and um,
really just criticize how abominable the
entire situation is and the fact that
the world, the world isn't turning a
blind eye, the US is turning a blind eye.
Um, you know, you say that the,
I took a controversial position,
but really it isn't controversial in
my mind because I'm looking at this
oppressed population that's in
prisoned. When I grew up, Joe,
I didn't even know first
of all what Palestine was.
And then when finally when I learned
about the Israeli Palestinian conflict,
even though it's really one sided,
um,
I started to learn about
what Gaza actually is.
And I think a lot of people don't even
understand when they hear the word Gaza
what they're talking about,
it's really what we're talking
about is an open air prison.
45 mile strip of land completely closed
off. Egypt's close their borders,
cc's just fucking sucking the Dick of
Netanyahu totally working together.
Netanyahu's shut off. The IDF is
closed off all the other boarders.
It's totally under siege.
There's 1.8 million people
living in that close quarters.
It's one of those densely
populated places on earth.
So whenever you have this
bombing campaign, people
are going to die and mass,
and when they say that
they're using human shields,
that's complete fucking bullshit.
I haven't seen one shred of evidence to
prove that they're using human shields
and fact,
if you look back at the last 60
years of US military conflicts,
they've used that term to demonize
populations whenever they want to make it
seem like this population
doesn't value human life.
You're telling me Palestinians
don't value their child's life,
that they're going to throw
their kids out in guard missiles.
All I've seen is cartoons from,
from Netanyahu,
these infographics that show
people standing on a house
with missiles underneath
total fucking bullshit. This place
has been under siege for years. Yes.
They may have said that they pulled their
troops out in 2007 it's under siege.
They, the Israeli health
official said that there,
they've tried to put them on a diet so
they only allow basic staples in they
claim because they didn't want the
Palestinians to be making weapons. Pasta,
paper, chocolate,
anesthetics, wheelchairs.
This is the shit that people
can't get inside Gaza.
They're keeping them gluten free.
It's been shown to reduce hostility.
The,
there was a documentary once
on suicide bombings and uh,
they had this Palestinian school and they
had the sign over the school that said
today's children are
tomorrow's holy martyrs.
And they had this child that was strapped
up with a c four and they had this
picture of this kid that had died in a
suicide bombing and they were praising
him like he was some sort of
a, you know, a saint, you know,
cause he died executing this.
So we'll just take,
we praise soldiers who go and drop white
phosphorous from plane. You know what,
what's more manly? Like when
you're, when you're driven to zero,
when you have nothing left,
that's when people blow themselves up.
It's not because it's
a culture of martyrdom,
it's because they have fucking nothing
and they don't have the industrial
warfare capabilities to
drop depleted uranium.
Right. Yeah. I'm certainly
not taking a side. Right.
But what I'm saying is that it's a,
it's an incredibly complicated situation.
Like A, I don't know
what, what Israel do to,
to like alleviate tension
to this point once,
like how many thousands of people have
died so far over 1500 at this 1500.
She's just Christ. 30%
children. I've seen photos.
Anthony Bordain tweeted some awful photo
of these children on the beach that had
been bombed and one kid was dad and
the other kid was being carried away,
most likely dead. It looked like by all
the blood and everything. It was just,
it's, it's so depressing.
It's so awful. And if you,
if you could objectively
stop the whole scene and say,
what is a way to fix this?
What is a way to alleviate this,
this horrible conflict?
What is it? Is there a way?
Well, I think up until now people have
been saying that two state solutions a
possibility or you had the Palestinian
Authority working with the Israeli
government.
Hamas has negotiated before.
It's not that they're
like ignoring Israel. Um,
and of course there's a lot of problems
with the moss and I'm not gonna sit here
and apologize for them.
They're really, I don't,
I don't agree with anything
that they want to see happen,
but I understand why Palestinians have
aligned themselves with this group
because the Palestinian Authority failed
so much and they could pitch related so
much to Israel.
So they basically turned to the more
militant faction of the leadership saying,
fucking do something.
At least you guys are resisting.
Because to them it's an occupation and
under the UN charter it's an occupation
as well.
A lot of people say the one state solution
is the only possibility which is end
the apartheid state give Palestinians
equal rights because right now there's
different laws if you're Arab,
that's what Israel is.
It's a Jewish state and they've driven
out people who are not Jewish and they're
ethnically cleansing them. It's a
fucking disaster, man. It's really scary.
And I don't actually blame Israelis
because you're growing up in Israel,
first of all,
they think that they're the chosen
people because the Bible says so,
which is disturbing in itself.
But second of all,
if you're growing up in Israel and you
do hear the sirens all the time and you
fucking think you're being told that
these people are terrorists and they want
to kill you. Right? Um, so I mean,
I don't blame it and, and, but,
but honestly Israel has much more
fair media coverage. They have hearts.
They have nine seven
two mag here in America.
We're treated like fucking children.
We aren't told the context
of the situation whatsoever.
All we're told is Hamas
terrorists keep firing it.
Israel and Israel has the
right to self defense.
Well,
in all fairness,
this is a topic that's really too
complicated for the news in quotes.
You're not going to get in a fox seven
minute sound bite in between commercials.
This is something that's
incredibly complex and really
should be like a three or
four hour documentary just
to scratch the surface.
And I don't know if,
I mean,
I guess if you call yourself the news,
there's a responsibility,
at least an implied responsibility to
educate when it comes to a situation like
this.
But to try to cover it on Fox News
or on CNN and to try to like give an
understanding to the people
viewing it seems almost impossible,
but they also just only do pro Israel
minus like that's why I did that video.
Why doesn't the media care
about dead Palestinians?
Because up until there was like hundreds
of Palestinians that had died already
and the news was still
making it seem like,
like literally every single headline was
just like three Israeli soldiers died,
400 others and you're like,
who are others?
Palestinians like human beings like fuck.
Are these people or would
just be like Israel's,
you know Hamas rockets have Israel
on edge. It's like, yeah, they had,
they might have Israel on edge,
but people are fucking like dying and
getting dismembered and getting blown up
like from bombs and all this
cease fire Shit, man. Look,
Aye, you're invading a country.
They are invading Gaza.
Netanyahu also said it doesn't matter,
ceasefire fire or not,
they're going to go through with the
invasion and destroyed the tunnels.
The tunnels are not just
used to store rockets.
The tunnels are used to
smuggle food into Gaza.
The tunnels are used to smuggle people
out to try to get them into Egypt because
they're wounded and injured on the news.
It is disgusting.
I've never seen anything so discussing
in my life than the bias toward Israel on
the media. And I know I'm called so many
names because I'm pointing this out,
but to me it's very obvious. My friend
right here, she's from South Africa.
She fucking, you know, she grew
up in a culture of post apartheid.
And we're living in a world where
an apartheid state exists right now.
And because of this tight allegiance
with the u s the u s supplies over $3
billion a year,
and just weaponry,
we're continuing to give more weapons
to Israel unless the US says something,
nothing's going to change.
And because it's this Jewish state,
if you criticize it,
then you must hate Jewish people.
And that's the problem is this rhetoric.
And it's so hard to break through
and to explain to people, look,
because I'm criticizing the government
doesn't mean that I hate the population.
I love all human beings.
I just want them to have sovereignty,
independence and equal rights.
Well,
there's also this undeniable problem
with having an area like that in what the
problem is, is that they're going to
be children that are born in that area,
that have no history of conflict
whatsoever, and they're fucked.
They're fucked.
This is where they live now and they're
treated as the enemy and they're born
into that and there's no chance to break
that cycle. And that sort of a scenario.
If you have a closed border,
you have a closed in population and
you have this demonized population,
there's no chance to break that struggle.
I mean,
if you're a child and you're born in
Palestine, what the fuck are the options?
Where are you going?
What's going on your,
and what are the ideologies that you're
confronted with constantly left and
right when you've got Hammas,
you've got all these Palestinian
organizations that want
to fight against Israel
and,
and you know you're growing.
You're growing up in this state
of perpetual conflict with it.
It doesn't seem like there's any
resolution that's conceivable. It's,
it's a terrible,
terrible tragedy.
It as far as like the wasted human
potential of the children that are born.
They're the people that are forced to
grow up in that environment as opposed to
Israel where they could just fucking
fly out and leave and live there.
And you know, I mean,
I, I'm not, you know,
I'm 100% against war. 100%.
Um, I don't think that wars,
the option here. I don't think
it's correct. I don't think,
I never think it's correct.
The only time it's ever,
I think the only time the military
should ever be used is when there's an
obvious threat.
You got some isis crazy
fucks are something that are
invading in a country and
having mass executions like what we're,
we're dealing with right now in Iraq.
That to me is a way clear example of
something that probably needs some fucking
military tension than anything that they
use to justify going to war with Iraq
in the first place. Like what they've
created in this vacuum is way scarier.
We're pulling out now while it's not
our problem. No, that's a real problem.
This is a real problem with you.
Fuckers. Did as you created a problem,
you created a power vacuum and now there's
a real problem because now you've got
militants who are so militant that
regular Islam is not militant enough for
them. They're blown up mosques.
These fuckers are blowing up.
Like these got training from the Syrian
holes that we gave them.
So it's like we embolden the Syrian
rebels that were aligned with this really
radical faction of Islam and then they
join up with Isis and now they're going
back to fucking Iraq. And
you're like, what in the hell?
This is why we shouldn't get involved.
This is why we shouldn't go
inject democracy in places
that are completely on a
different evolutionary
path of, you know, culture.
Duncan and I had dinner last night after
the show and we were talking about this
and we're both like shaking her head.
And one of the things that we kept coming
to is like when ever you have military
action,
whenever you kill a thousand people,
you don't just kill a thousand people.
You also make widows,
you make loved ones who hate the
lost their friends and family.
And there's just this, this culture of
hate that just never goes away. It's,
it's as long as the, yeah, as
long as those people are alive,
this cycle is just ingrained in them
on both sides, on the Israeli side,
on the Palestinian side, it's just
horrific. And it's almost like this,
this process that's
impossible to completely stop.
Like once the blood is shed, like,
fuck man. It's like, you know,
it just, it creates, this is
unfixable problem. I see it and it, okay.
So we created this Jewish state, the US
help create this Jewish state Israel. Um,
then there was, you know, the anti
photos and then they had their borders.
And basically what's happened is that
Israel has continued to encroach and if
you look at the math,
there's like this map.
This is very famous picture of these four
factions of how Israel has encroached
more and more in Palestine. And now
it just closed off. More and more.
Gaza's just shrunk to about this big.
The westbank has shrunk to about this big
and they continue to build settlements
against international law.
They've violated all of these
like international treaties
to continue doing this
because more and more settlers are going
over there and, and making a home base,
demolishing homes left and right.
Um, so if you look at the conflict,
it depends on when you
want to start the clock.
You can start it with the kidnappings,
which Hamas actually didn't do in Israel,
had to admit to that.
Or you can start with the two kids that
were executed on camera by IDF soldiers
weeks prior to that.
Or You could start with fucking 50 years
ago or you could start with fucking
3000 years ago. I mean, when, when you
want to start the conflict or the clock,
the conflict and not really all depends
on the context of the situation,
but when people say like, well,
you're fucking shooting rockets at us,
what do you think we're going to do?
The problem is you have to understand
why they're shooting rockets and no one
wants to talk about that.
And no one wants to talk about how if
you have a helpless population under
section 51 under the UN Charter,
that if you're getting fucking peddled
with industrial warfare and you don't
have an army and your help
us population being occupied,
you do have the right to defend
yourself. That's the UN. Um, I'm not,
I abhor violence on either side and I
completely condemn shooting rockets into
civilian populations and uh,
trying to kill people.
But I do understand the
resistance movement.
I do understand people aligning
with Hamas because look,
they're under fucking siege.
And if I didn't have basic
amenities and if I saw my home,
like my neighbor's homes
getting demolished all my
life and I five fucking saw
people getting shot and beat the shit
out of all my Palestinian friends friends
here who have left Palestine
over the years, their stories
are just unbelievable.
One of them's brother was beaten to death
by the IDF when he was 16 because he
threw a stone. The other one lost
six family members and one bombing.
And I'm just like, how the fuck do
you guys go on? And they're like,
just surviving. Is our resistance
just living as our resistance? I mean,
I,
and everyone has a story like that.
The end, there's incredible
biases. Um, on the side of the,
the pro Israel side. Like, I've,
I've seen some videos that make you just
go w w w what the Dennis Prager one is
the most egregious if you ever seen
them. Now what is it? We'll play.
It will play it because
it's quite fascinating.
I'm Dennis Prager on
the Palestine, um, uh,
Israeli conflict.
It's like he,
he breaks it down in this way
that like, uh, it's, it's very,
it's a highly criticized video.
Um, in a nutshell. Yes. Yes.
Let's play it.
Let's do it because it's a,
it's one of those ones where
you're like, okay, come on man. Uh,
well I'll, I'll, we'll
play it here. You got it.
Because it's something that you can't
really describe without actually,
cause Dennis Prager is this like serious,
conservative Jewish Fella, right?
Prager university. By the way, you can't
have Prager university. You're fuck,
you know, you're not a God damn
professor of a university that you,
Oh,
a Prager university is you give us five
minutes and we'll give you a semester.
Well, I took many more stories on the
question of the Middle East conflict.
I was at the Middle East Institute.
In fact, that Columbia University,
that's where I did my graduate work
semester after semester discussing the
Middle East conflict as if it were the
most complex conflict in the world,
when in fact it's probably the easiest
conflict in the world to describe.
It may be the hardest to solve,
but it really is the easiest
to describe kill all Muslims.
And really in a nutshell,
this is what it is.
Israel would like to and recognizes
the right of the Palestinians to have a
state. The Palestinians, however,
and many other Muslims and Arabs do not
recognize the right of a Jewish state of
Israel to exist.
Every poll among Palestinians shows that
the majority of Palestinians want there
to be no Jewish state of Israel doesn't
believe that it should exist or had any
basis for being.
And this has been true since 1948 when
the British left and the UN established
eight division Palestine will be
cut in half Jewish half and an Arab.
Half the Jews accepted it.
The Arabs didn't accept it.
And what happened the
moment it was announced,
Arab armies about seven Arab armies
attacked the Jewish state in order to
destroy it. To everybody's surprise,
the little Jewish state survive.
And that was pretty much it.
And then it happened again in 1967 when
the dictator of Egypt Gamal Abdel Nasser
said, we are now going to extinguish
the Jewish state of Israel.
And Jordan joined him and Syria
joined him, but Israel attack first.
And so Israel survive.
And that is how Israel and only that way
came to occupy what was called the West
Bank of Jordan,
where many Palestinians live because
many Palestinians lived in that part of
Jordan. So the war was over in
67 and a lot of the Arabs do.
The Arab states all went to Khartoum
Sudan and announced no recognition,
no peace and no negotiations.
The three famous knows what
was Israel supposed to do.
Then Israel made an agreement to give
the entire Sinai peninsula and area of
land bigger than Israel with oil back to
Egypt because they said they would make
peace with Israel.
Israel gives territory back for
peace and it will always do that,
but is there really a desire for
peace on the part of Israel's enemies,
which broadcast after broadcast on TV
and radio and the Palestinian areas is
about how Jews should be killed and
how a law once a Jews to be killed.
That's the typical broadcast
on Palestinian television,
so it's not hard to explain
the Middle East dispute.
One side wants the other debt.
You know what the motto of Hamas is?
The motto of Hamas is we love death
as much as the Jews love life.
Now you tell me how was this real
supposed to make peace when people believe
what? Hamas beliefs. Oh
God, where do I start now?
Here is one of the most important
thing nobody talks about.
Everybody talks about a Palestinian state.
Why didn't anybody talk
about a Palestinian state
while the Palestinians lived
on the Jordanian rule?
Because the truth is people started
talking about a Palestinian state once the
Palestinians were under Israeli rule
because it was always a way to destroy the
Jewish state of Israel and I saved you
were state because that's what it is.
There are many, many Arab states,
but there was only one Jewish state.
It is about the size of New Jersey.
In fact,
Israel is the size of El Salvador,
El Salvador,
and yet if a Martian came to the earth
and they visited the United Nations
newspapers or watched
the world television,
they would believe that the
biggest problem on earth
is a state the size of New
Jersey and El Salvador.
This state of Israel,
this preoccupation with a little
democratic humane state is absolutely
irrational.
And here's another question to be asking.
If Israel tomorrow put down its arms
and said, we will fight no more,
what would happen if the Arab
countries around Israel said,
we will fight no more. We put down our
arms. What would happen in the first case?
There would be an immediate destruction
of the state of Israel with mass murder
of the Jews of Israel.
In the second scenario I presented where
the Arabs put down their arms and said,
we just want peace. They would be
the next Wednesday. The fact is,
as I said at the outset,
it is a very simple problem to describe.
One side wants the other
debt and if they didn't,
there would be peace and
yet please remember this.
There has never been never in the history
of the world a state in that area,
in what is called geographically
Palestine that was not Jewish.
Israel is the third autonomous
Jewish state to exist in that area.
There was never on autonomous Arab state.
There was never an autonomous Muslim
state. There was never an autonomous,
any other state.
That's the issue.
Why can't a little state the size of
El Salvador that calls itself Israel be
allowed to exist? That in a
nutshell is the Middle East problem.
I'm Dennis Prager.
Dennis Prager is a Douche bag.
I love how he's like, um, okay,
so you have all these Arab states
and this is the only Jewish state.
Arab isn't a fucking religion
idiot Jewish state. Yeah,
you have an Islamic state of Iran,
but are you going to really
compare the fucking too,
if you're claiming that Israel is the
only democracy in the Middle East,
are you really comparing yourself
to Iran and all these other like,
I mean it's just amazing that he just
said that. That's insane also. Sure.
There's absolutely people
who hate Jewish people.
There's calls for genocide on that side,
but there's also calls for genocide
and the Israeli cabinet as well.
Some woman just said that
all Palestinians should die.
Times of Israel just published
a piece justifying genocide.
They actually said when justify
when genocide is permissible.
This was just published
yesterday, taken down, um,
in a couple of hours because of
the backlash. But you have this,
this rhetoric coming from both sides,
but I only see one side actually doing
the genocide carrying out genocide.
Um, one side is doing the
killing the other side. Yes.
Hamas charter may say that
Israel should seize to exist.
I don't know if that's like
a mistranslation in Arabic
of just saying the state
should be dissolved, but I know that
they missed translated document.
Dennis shod saying wipe Israel off the
map. He never actually said that. Um,
he just,
he said like the borders should like
Israel as a state shouldn't be there as a
Jewish state. He didn't say fucking
wipe them off the map, killed them all.
That was a mistranslation.
And of course you just hear that
repeated ad nauseum no matter what. Um,
one other thing that's just really
ridiculous is this other Israeli cabinet
official just said that Palestinians
are committing self genocide.
That every time the Palestinian child
dies it's because they're killing
themselves.
I guess there must be rockets inside of
these children because I haven't seen
any evidence whatsoever.
All the homes of they're blowing up.
Where are these rocket command centers?
I just want to see fucking evidence.
It's not a cartoon.
Well, Prager's uh, his point
of views, very simplified,
very simplistic and biased.
Obviously, you know, his, the,
the whole take like it's very simple.
The Jewish state.
It's very simple. It's not very
simple. It's not simple at all, man.
And he didn't mention what you mentioned
at all is that these people are kind of
closed in there and there's no
hope for them. This idea that,
you know,
first of all,
the idea that a Jewish state
has always gives a fuck.
It's religions retarded. All
right, if you're an old man,
you think religions are good idea,
good on you buddy.
Keep that rock that shit until you
fucking body stops working. But for us,
for the young folks that are out here
that had sort of paying attention to the
way things have run on this planet
in this idiotic cyclical manner,
from the beginning of time,
from the beginning,
the first fucking dude wrote shit down
and decided to tell the other guys that
God wrote it or God told him to
write it or what. I mean, that's it.
This idea that it's the religious
state should be allowed to exist.
The idea of a religious state
is ridiculous. It's ridiculous.
Whether it's a state of Scientology,
whether it's the moonies have
their own fucking country.
Like any country that is based
on religion. It's ridiculous.
It's ridiculous.
And I know we're supposed to have
religious freedom and I agree with that.
I agree that you should fucking,
you should be able to worship
the spaghetti monster.
You should be able to
do whatever you want.
But when you have an entire state that
bling believes it's the chosen people and
they're connected to this other state
that they have sort of boxed into this 45
mile strip,
I mean objectively stand
outside of the situation.
What are those poor people you're
supposed to do? You know, and look, I'm,
I am not discounting this idea that Hamas
is a terrorist organization cause they
obviously are, but how, how does a
terrorist organizations start out?
It's like one of the things that happened
during September 11th it drove me
fucking bananas when George Bush was like,
they hate us for our freedom, you know?
Okay.
W W w they hate us so much for our
freedom that they're willing to fly planes
into buildings.
What did we do right?
What the fuck are we doing
that gets people angry?
Nobody ever thinks about that.
All they ever think about
is the action themselves.
Not like what's causing this action?
What is it that's making people come
from another planet and blow up buildings
in New York City? Well, it's not New
York City. It's not those people.
It's not the people in those busy
not freedom. It's not freedom.
It has nothing to do with it.
It's this discounting of the chain
of events that cause this cataclysmic
disaster. It's discounting
the, the, the pressures, the,
the inequities, the, the, all
the problems, the inequality,
tha tha tha tha the despair of being
born into that situation and this is the
idea that what the thing that drives me
the most crazy about war is that people
will agree that those people are the
enemy. People that they don't even know,
right? They're just people. This, this,
this concept of tribalism is so
archaic and so fucking stupid that it,
it drives me crazy that it still exists.
That in this day and age,
people who have never met,
we'll see someone who's on the
other side of the fence and say,
that is my enemy and I have to go
kill them. People who have never met,
they don't know each other at all.
And this idea that these people are
Arab and these people are Jewish,
so they could never possibly get a wrong.
It's preposterous saying it exists
all throughout this country.
We w people, I mean, yeah,
there's racism and there's there,
there's biases against religions
and religious beliefs for sure.
But there's also,
there's always going to be that there's
bias against Republicans hate fucking
Democrats. Democrats hate Republicans,
but a lot of people hate libertarians.
People love to hate
people for all regardless.
And when the media is amplifying that
hate and telling you more reasons why you
should hate the, it's
the same logic. Okay,
so Hamas is the democratically
elected leadership of the Gaza Strip.
And the reason is because
of what I said before,
is that they're aligning more with this
militant faction because they are trying
to resist this occupation
and ongoing seizure. Right.
I disagree with Hamas is
all of what they stand for.
But I understand the evolution
of how this happened,
but it's the same logic as saying all
Palestinians deserve to die because they
liked it. Hamas. They all
must be terrorist. They
almost believe in that shit.
It's the same logic bin Ladin had that
Americans deserve to die because you know
of what we did,
right?
Because we elected these leaders
who you could say are terrorists.
I'm just a larger scale.
What makes someone a terrorist?
Killing a million Iraqis with all this
fucking high grade weaponry or blowing
yourself up on an airplane. I mean
it's comparable. If you're looking at,
I would say that the a million
daddy Rockies would say
that Bush was a terrorist.
You know, one man's terrorist is
another man's freedom fighter.
Yeah.
It's easy to point.
It's easy to decide that someone's a
terrorist and that will label terrorist is
such a right. It's so vague
and it's so easy. Move around.
You know, he could, he could
apply it to either side,
but the dehumanization of populations.
My brother Robbie Martin, he's yelled,
he does journalism for media roots.org,
which is my other citizen
journalism website.
But we just published this article about
the history of the term human shield
and it just, it is really
incredible because you look
back at even World War II,
Japan,
the Vietcong,
we all use this terminology and there's
really little evidence to ever back it
up. And it always is when
the establishment wants to
paint a population as like
having little value to human life,
even bin Ladin using as
wives as human shields.
When we raided the compound that turned
out to be an ally, um, the Taliban,
they said that they use people as human
shields shooting from civilian areas.
All of this like never
really has been proven,
but when you repeat it more and more and
more and more, people just say like, oh,
well they're using their
kids as human shields.
What are we supposed to do when we
go in there and bomb them? Like,
it's not our fault that
the kids are dying.
Here's isn't even fucking crazier part.
As you remember this,
when we invaded Iraq Bush,
actually,
so the CIO has this giant document on
human shields and Saddam is use of human
shields. And Bush actually fucking had
the audacity to go out on TV and say,
just to warn you, there's going to be
mass casualties when we invaded Iraq.
And he was like,
but it's going to be because he Rockies
are going to be used as human shields.
He was like, the people who die, Saddam,
we'll be using them as human shields.
Like how the fucking insane is that the,
you're preemptively justifying slaughter
by blaming the population that you're
going to be bombing. I sorry, I
just get really upset. Well, you
shouldn't be. You should be, because
these tactics are ridiculous. You know,
and this, these, these tactics,
they're a part of an ancient system,
right?
This ancient system of justification
of warfare and this ancient system,
it really,
you know,
for the longest time it was
incredibly difficult to decipher.
Incredibly difficult. I mean,
go back to the Roman days,
try to figure out who's right
and who's wrong. Good luck.
What are you going to find
the right animal skin to read?
You know where it has the fucking
truth written down on it? No, you,
you couldn't possibly be there when the
events transpired that caused the war
itself. You couldn't possibly
be in the tent where the, the,
the war chiefs decided to fucking,
you know me.
This is the attack we're going to do and
this is the reason why we're going to
do it. No, you,
you just were a part of the army or you
are part of the civilian population that
had to endure whatever was going on.
You felt powerless.
You felt you had no information other
than what was being spread through the
state and you were fucked.
But now we live in this different time
and in this different time you can watch
a Dennis Prager video and go Dennis
Prager as a Douche bag. You can debate it.
You can,
you can look at the actual facts of the
situation and people can be informed in
a way that's really never
been available before. The,
the Vietnam war protests
were largely based on the,
there were largely based on
educational institutions.
It was largely largely based
out of universities where
these liberal professors
were trying to explain to people what
the reality of the situation was.
And then parents are like, these fucking
liberals are teaching my kids bullshit.
And then you had Kent state
where the fucking the military,
the national guard came in
and shot student protestors
and scare the fuck out of
everybody.
I mean there was so much chaos going
on to try to suppress the spread of
information.
Just tried to suppress dissent.
But today the wells broken.
I mean it's just,
there's no suppressing it any more.
And we have these organizations that are
scrambling to try to make sense of it
all that trying to
justify their actions in,
in light of this overwhelming amount of
information that didn't exist before.
Exactly. Social media, the wouldn't
during operation cast lead,
which was I think I want to say 2009 but
that was the last really brutal siege
on Gaza and we didn't have
social media like we did. I'm in,
they didn't have it back
then like we do now.
So I think they're able to control
the narrative a little bit more.
But now it's like the fucking
floodgates are opened. Dude.
You can't deny seeing children's brains
being blown out. I mean it's just,
there's so much death and destruction
on social media that you're just seeing
the truth right in your fucking face.
It doesn't matter how many
cartoon infographics you
make up on the IDF sided and
going back to propaganda,
I mean Israel is just working 24,
seven to try to spin this thing.
Um,
not only as our media an abysmal failure
and relaying what is actually happening,
but they actually have,
um, you know, first of all,
there's the birthright trip where actually
I think like 2000 soldiers right now
and the idea for American,
because they go on these birthright
trips and then they're told at the end of
the trip,
like,
come fight for us like you need this is
like everyone wants to kill us still.
You know, Jews need protection and come
join the IDF. And it's just bizarre.
I can't imagine another army,
well actually I can,
and they were called terrorists when
people wanted to join like the Iraqi
resistance and the Syrian resistance,
we call them terrorists.
But if you're an American, you go fucking
join the IDF, which is a colonial army.
Somehow you're a fucking hero.
The propaganda machines working 24 seven,
they offer grants,
scholarships for people who can do the
most pro Zionist editing on Wikipedia and
edit the most Facebook posts and post
the most pro tweets, pro Israel treats.
They offer free hotter balloon
rides around Israel. Tel Aviv.
If you post the most pro Israeli
shit on like Facebook and Twitter.
Dude, it's pretty sweet though. Hot Air
balloon who we didn't want to do that.
Right. I'm thinking about it and
I mean I doubt Hamas is offering,
like I've dropped him off with
the capability to offer that to,
to the all the fucking
human shields in Gaza,
but I don't even have pasta or chocolate.
Yeah,
they're going to have hot air balloons.
They can't even make terrorist
paper airplanes point to paper. Uh,
but it just shows you how much is going
into the spin machine on one side.
And I was invited on CNN last night
and I was like shocked. I was like,
holy fuck, they're gonna let me go
on CNN and drop this truth on there.
And then they cancelled. I think
they got some pressure, um,
because it was too good to be, yeah. Oh,
good googly Mowgli. Of course they
did. Yeah. Someone was probably like,
no, no, no, no, no. Watch her videos,
bitch crazy.
Got a nose ring.
Yeah. Um, it's, this is a strange
time when it comes to this,
uh,
these,
these sort of events because they don't
play out the way the military leaders
sort of expect them to play out in the
media anymore because the media that's
online is as big,
if not bigger in total.
Then the mainstream in quotes media,
there's no mainstream media anymore.
There's CNN, there's Fox, there's
these traditional media outlets,
which is the way to describe them.
Traditional media.
It's almost like they're their legacy.
It's like legacy media.
But then there's online media,
which if you totaled up the amount
of blogs, the amount of videos,
the amount of online websites that have
streaming video and podcasts and the
different forms of media that
exists that cover these same issues.
It's overwhelmingly bigger.
Overwhelmingly like the numbers are
much larger for the cumulative total of
websites that cover these stories.
It's,
it's much more people are downloading
like clicking on those links,
reading those stories,
watching those videos.
Then you're getting
ever on a CNN broadcast.
So that's why I didn't even care when
they canceled it. I was like, fuck it,
I'm going on Joe Rogan's show tomorrow.
And that has a million times more.
Just like people who I would even
want to be reaching out to you.
Like what do I want to reach out to
like old ladies in their home watching
fucking Fox or do I want to reach
out to people who actually, you know,
have that are on the ball or like invested
in the culture and what the fuck's
happening in this country. And that's
your audience. And it's just really cool.
I mean being at your show last
night and seeing and seeing,
just like how many people give a shit
and are paying attention to you and the
podcast and fuck CNN it,
we're driving them into a relevancy man.
I mean your show and all the social media
stuff, these people, it's dinosaurs.
There's not dying. The silent movies,
what it is, the format is archaic,
you know, we'll be right back. You know,
and like these fucking things drive me
crazy when they have a legitimate issue
to debate and they have four squares.
Like it's the fucking Hollywood squares
and rip is up in the corner and he's
like this. That's correct. Right.
Chase is nuts. And then you know,
you have all these other people and
they're yelling over each other and like
we'll be right back. Thank you for,
yeah, we have to cut to Justin Bieber.
He just got it
court and that's what they actually did.
They like cut from a congress.
I mean I think CNN or
something was cutting and he
was talking to a congressman
about the NSA and then they're like,
hold on, breaking news, Justin Bieber.
Just like pled something.
I was like, what? Yeah. Um,
yeah,
I mean if I could just say one thing,
so people don't call me a
Nazi and shit is that I,
I love all people.
I think all human beings,
I just want to see humanity have equality
and I just think that the Palestinians
are being royally fucked over and I'm
just totally disgusted with the way that
it's being portrayed and that they're
being vilified and demonized with zero
context and zero historical
context of how this happened.
And that's why I'm just like trying
to just say as much as I can,
even though I'm very
biased and openly biased.
I'm an advocacy journalist and I just
think that it needs to be done because I
see just a giant void in the main stream
and I just got to fucking do it. I mean,
I interviewed some woman in
Gaza who she was just like,
I could be called the human shield
because I'm refusing to leave my house.
And she's like, and the truth is
there's nowhere for us to go. Yeah,
we can't leave.
Right.
45 miles and that many people
stuffed in together. It's the,
the options are incredibly limited.
And if you really want to do,
if anybody in that area
really wants to have peace,
this idea that you contain these people,
it was almost like insuring, yeah,
you're ensuring that you're going
to have some sort of conflict,
constant conflict. I don't know
what to do though, but I mean,
what are you gonna do?
You're gonna let those people,
if you let those people out of Gaza,
okay. Like say if the, the, the, the,
the Jews and the Palestinians come to
an agreement and then they open the
borders and then the Palestinians come
over to Israel and they seek revenge for
their family members that have died.
And then it all starts all over again.
I mean,
once thousands of people have been killed
and it sends in their eyes murdered,
you know, you can say military
action. It's call, you know,
use whatever noises with your face to
describe a missile hitting a fucking baby.
But it is what it is.
And if that's my baby,
I'm strapping some c four to my chest
and I'm going to find out who did it and
I'm going to take out the whole group.
I mean that's probably
what they're thinking.
And there's going to be
a lot of those people.
There's a lot of those people
that are filled with despair.
And what other options? I
don't know. I don't know.
Good point.
And I think that's the reason why
these 120 people are still languishing,
innocent and getting though,
because at this point they're like,
what the fuck are we going
to do release these people?
We just tortured them for 12 years.
Well, we tortured some folks. We tortured
to boat. Did you see that fucking thing?
Oh my God. Folks, if you haven't
seen it folks, ladies and gentlemen,
there is a recent thing where
Barack Obama is talking.
Okay
bout people being tortured
and he uses the term.
Well, we tortured some folks
after the September 11 attacks.
Tortured some folks. No, you
can't say that. You can say,
we met some folks, you
know, ah, we went to,
we went to Atlanta. We met
some Nice folks. You don't
say we tortured some folks.
Like what kind of fucking weird euphemism
speak is that we tortured some folks.
So that's become a Hashtag on Twitter now.
A Hashtag we tortured some
folks Hashtag drone king. Yeah,
that is what's going on that
I'm not kidding. That is uh,
that's trending Hashtag we tortured
some folks. I'm not kidding.
And that's exactly, yeah,
that's exactly what,
what's happening with the
drone wars that look, these,
these fucking Taliban militants just took
over this airport and Karachi killed a
shitload people.
And why?
Because they said that a drone fucking
killed one of their leaders in fucking
the rural area of Pakistan because
Obama launched a drone attack.
Killed this guy.
It's like this is going
to be going on forever.
When you kill people with drones,
when you fucking in prison,
people a in a little area.
I mean,
it just going to be a cycle of
violence and revenge and a hate. Um,
and that's why I just completely
disagree with, with, you know,
of course the drone war. I disagree with
all that Shit, man. Oh, bonds are there.
It's a spooky idea that you're nowhere
near there and you have a remote control
and you press a button and missiles
that are called a hell fire.
Missiles come flying out of the sky and
slamming a targets often the wrong ones.
And if you look at the amount of people
that are innocent that had been killed
by drones versus the amount of actual
terrorists that have been killed by drunk,
what a fucking mess that up.
And they also just call a militants.
Anyone who's just aged like
literally military age.
So it could be 15 to fucking a
hundred if you're a military age male,
you're considered a militant.
So who are, I mean, yeah,
I don't know who's even like, I'm sure the
majority of them are civilians. If you,
if you have enough dirt on
someone where you actually,
they're worthy of being executed,
put them on fucking trial. I'm sorry.
But I believe in the
rule of law and justice.
I don't believe in just assassinating
motherfuckers across the globe with zero
accountability,
zero context of who these people are.
And we know that they've executed
fucking like that. 16 year old boy,
the son of Anwar, all all Locky. Yeah.
16 year old kid blew him up in a drone.
Him and his whole family just dead.
No accountability,
no rationale and you know
there are just all terrorists.
I guess that's just makes us feel better.
I guess to think that in Pakistan alone
between 416 and 951 civilians including
hundred and 68 to 200 children have been
killed depending upon reports and
you know, who knows what the numbers,
the correct numbers are.
I mean first of all you got a real problem
with incredibly poor people where you
hit a fucking house where they live in
and there's no paperwork and there are
blown to smithereens.
Like how many people were there.
You were going to have to find the family
members are going to report and tell
you how many, and it's, you know, that's
why you're getting these weird numbers,
but the bottom line is hundreds of
people have been murdered that did.
And also more disturbing linked
to disturbing things. One of them,
the intercept release,
which is Glenn Greenwald's publication
with the NSA leaks that they actually are
killing people based on metadata.
So they track someone's metadata through
their cell phone and then they track
all these patterns. So it's not even
like real human beings with an, you know,
conducting intelligence on the ground,
figuring out what people
deserve to die or not.
It's actually fucking tracking metadata
on a fucking like computer screen.
That is insane to me because what if you
give your cell phone or your grandma,
right, the cell phones in your
grandma's house or a church,
they're going to fucking blow the
shit out of that church. Exactly.
Blow your grandma targeting
wherever that phone, you know,
if you really hated somebody, you just
leave your phone over their house. Hell,
fire is a comment.
Yeah,
that's specific.
And so the idea of the,
this is the word that gets thrown
around a lot, surgical strikes.
I mean you want to talk
about surgical precision.
You don't usually talk about
missiles that hit metadata
that where a phone is and it's a
hit in a fucking apartment building.
You're just going to blow
up. Whoever happens to random
Billy be near this phone,
collateral damage man. And
going back to what do we do?
I mean, I think that we, um,
we end the apartheid state.
We start giving Arabs equal rights,
but I think that the u s
cutting off funding militarily,
I think is the number one
thing. I mean, for God's sake,
there's been blatant war crimes that have
happened hitting the UN refugee school,
killing 17 human beings that we're trying
to get refuge during a humanitarian
sees far, they bombed a crowded
market, killing another 17.
They've killed like six journalists,
target all these media centers at,
and then there was a UN Security Council
where every single country either
abstained or voted to investigate war
crimes in Gaza except the u s except the u
s that's how blind,
that's how blind this allegiances.
And if we could just end
this military funding,
I think then Israel would be forced
to kind of analyze their, their role.
And we can really talk seriously about
solutions here because it's not going to
work.
Yeah. You're not anti Israel,
you're anti war right. You know,
and I have a lot of friends
that are Jewish and you know,
on a lot of them have very strong opinions
about this whole thing. And you know,
I see it from their point of view.
They grew up with this idea that the
Palestinians are terrorists or the
Palestinians kidnap,
choose.
And you remember the Olympic Games
and all this craziness. And you know,
I see their point of view.
But as an objective human observer,
when you watch us, you go, there has
gotta be a way to break this cycle.
And the way is not missiles and
it's not blowing up tunnels.
And it's not keeping these
people on a strip of land.
I don't know what the way is.
You know, that's the problem.
I'm talking a lot of shit here. I don't
have any solutions, but uh, it's scary.
It's scary as fuck.
And then you've got Russia that
may be invading Ukraine right now.
I mean, as we speak this weekend,
that might be going down. You know,
there's a bunch of points all over the
earth where there's some scary shit
that's happening. You know,
it's, this is scary time.
It's a very scary time because human
beings have so much more capacity for
violence. We, we the, our ability,
when you have things like drones,
when you have things like long range
missiles and nuclear weapons and all these
different things that just
didn't exist a hundred years ago,
but you still have the same mentality
that existed a hundred years ago.
That's the real issue, right? I
mean, a hundred years ago, you know,
you had a fucking get in a boat and you
had to get over there in a plane with a
propeller and it was, it was hard to
fuck shit up. Now you can be in Nevada,
you know, with a fucking x box controller
and you're launching missiles, you know,
from the other side of the world
is it gets real weird when
it becomes easy to kill.
And when you're so delusional that you
think that you are literally chosen by
God to live more than another human being,
and then you have these weapons in your
arsenal. That's what's scary to me.
That's goofy as fuck. That is unbelievably
goofy. And that's the thing that,
you know, when you, when you talk
to Jewish people, that's, you know,
that's my faith and my undeniable
right to have this faith.
And that's why Dennis Prager, boy,
my face, like undeniable, right?
For a Jewish state, look, undeniably,
there's so much fucking antisemitism
online. It's disgusting. It's vile.
And there's obviously Jews had been
persecuted horribly in the past and um,
you know,
it's awful,
but it's not a reason or justification
to do this to another population. No,
no, it's not. And it's only
gonna make more antisemitism.
So unfortunate attacking Palestinians and
seen and having the outside world look
at this happen and you know, and also
look, when Palestinians attack Israelis,
that shit ain't helping
either, man. Right? But it's,
it's a terribly imbalanced situation, a
terribly, terribly imbalanced situation.
It's imbalanced that Israel feels like
it's completely surrounded by these Arab
states, these Muslim states
that hate it and want it gone.
That's incredibly imbalanced as well.
And that's also a religious issue.
It's like that they're just as goofy,
the whole, I mean, it's all goofy.
This idea that your ideology,
your religious ideology based on some
ancient shit that nobody knows the real
source of is more important or
more valid than someone else's.
It's all fucking madness. And look
at us, look at the Christian College.
Here are the evangelicals did,
I just saw,
I don't know if you've been watching
John Oliver, I really liked his show,
but he had on this stuff about the
Uganda gay La and you're like, oh wow,
that's so fucked up.
Uganda has such horrible galas.
And then you realize that it's because
of the evangelicals here in this country
that they basically been in bolden because
the political establishment for some
reason it takes them seriously enough
to like let them and have such a say and
it's driven all of our politics
of the fucking right so much.
And so then these evangelicals have
so much money and backing that they go
across the world and start like making
these laws get pushed through to fucking
kill gay people. And you're like,
what in the hell is going on?
It's this crazy shit. Like
sure. Uganda's uh, you know,
might be backwards in a lot of ways,
but without these American Christian
evangelicals going over there and actually
helping get this done,
it wouldn't have happened.
And that's really scary because for
some reason they're relevant here.
And I'm not saying of course, if you're
Christian, I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about the very, very,
very right wing, very like money,
like very small minority that have
extremely powerful political voice because
they have so much money and
it gets people like, you know,
Mitt Romney and fucking
Rick Santorum. Yeah, I mean,
I mean the fact that those
people are even relevant.
The fact that we had that as
our president, like, look,
I think Obama is a war criminal,
but Mitt Romney's, I mean, damn,
I mean these people are just nuts.
Sarah Pailin, these people should not
anywhere near politics when fucking crazy.
Mitt Romney,
for folks who don't know is a part of one
of the most extreme Mormon sex effort.
They left the country to go to Mexico
because he couldn't have a hundred wives
here in America.
That's mean this literally why Mitt
Romney's family couldn't know his dad
couldn't be president because his
dad was born in fucking Mexico.
His family is from Mexico.
They have a giant compound in Mexico
where they are engaged in like these wars
with the drug cartels.
They get kidnapped and Shit.
Vice did this whole piece on it. It's
incredibly fucked up and Mitt Romney's is.
They just did. No one talked about
it. My Mormonism is off the table.
You're like, actually that's
pretty fucking important. No it's,
it's on the table as fuck dude.
You know you might keep it off
the table and you're goofy.
Legacy television shows and all these
ridiculous things that you, you,
you do these ridiculous debates
where everything's controlled.
If I was ever in a debate with that guide,
the first thing I would say is
you really believe Joseph Smith,
a 14 year old boy found golden tablets
that contain the loss work of Jesus,
but only he could read them cause he had
a magic barium and then no one else can
see the fuck outta here.
Dude. I would literally say,
get the fuck out of here on TV.
You're in a cult, right? Yeah.
You called Sir big sometimes,
sometimes culturally of 30 people.
And you live in the fucking San Fernando
Valley in a weird shelter and sometimes
called have a billion people.
And you know,
you've got a guy called the pope and
he sits on a fucking golden throne.
Guess what? That guy's a
fucking cult leader. Right?
You know, maybe the new ones,
the best one ever because
he's, you know, he's,
he's sweet and he's a man of the people
and he's so proletariat. Look at him.
He's an awesome pope. He's
a regular guy. No he's not.
He's just a better cult leader then that
creepy fuck that came before him that
sat on a golden throne,
you know,
and had a gay bath house in
the same property as exactly.
Thank you for bringing that up. Well, I'd,
I know l Ron Hubbard, his great grandson,
he lives in Oakland and he
was telling me that his,
it's very openly admitted and his great
grandfather wrote it in fucking books
and shit,
that he was in tax trouble.
And he needed to start a religion to
like get out of this fucking tax trouble.
He was gonna go to jail, he owed
tons of money, the government.
And he even said like,
I'm going to start a fucking religion
and get myself out of these like tax
problems and wow,
here you go.
Yeah,
he did it.
And to take that Scientology is
any less valid than Mormonism,
right?
Or that Mormonism is any less valid than
a religion that is based on a Jewish
Zombie thought. All of it's silly, man.
And it's not saying that there's no god,
it's not saying that spirituality doesn't
have some sort of a benefit to our
society and our culture and this idea
of a greater thing other than people.
This greater power,
whatever it may be that created the
universe because there is something that
runs this world,
something that runs
this universe.
You want to give it scientific terms,
you want to give it philosophical term,
whatever it is.
There's obviously a giant energy that is
created this massive fucking universe,
whether it has a consciousness or not
is d you could debate it all day long,
but I'm guessing that a dude didn't die
and then three days later come out and
push a rock aside and you know,
come on.
It's the myths that
holds society together.
It's all these fables and myths that are
the glue and you're talking about how
we haven't really changed.
We fucking haven't dude.
I just saw a poll that basically if a
president was atheist that would be like
the least favorable factor of like any
candidate running for president is if
they didn't believe in God. That's how
important religion still is to society.
And I think that even it's like we were
saying last night at the comedy show
that you can show someone proof that
big foot that this video is fucking fake
and if,
and they still want to believe it,
they believe it doesn't matter
if you just say like, look,
Jonah couldn't have survived
inside of a whale for three days.
It's just not scientifically possible
like
condos in the whales.
Yeah.
People are,
people are weird man there where would
their beliefs and what's weird is as long
as something's old will accept it.
But if you tried to come out today with
some Jewish Zombie story and people will
be like, what is this asshole
doing it? They put you on pills.
They'd be like good on psychoactive
medicine. You were sucking. Yeah.
If you were standing like in the middle
of all the people in Occupy Wall Street
and you, you had a a chart and you
were holding up this, this chart,
this is how the earth was
formed 6,000 years ago.
In six days He created this. He'd be like,
bitch, are you out of your fucking mind?
If everybody just believe
wholeheartedly in science,
if we had completely abandoned all
religion and then you came along with
aversion and nobody would take it.
It has to be old to be old,
but when it's old we'll accept goofy shit.
Ooh.
Though it's so much fucking
shit has come out since then.
Even though were the internet, we have
the world's knowledge at our fingertips.
We still believe in these
archaic philosophies that
do not apply anymore. Dude,
did you hear about the Blackwater
Shit that came out? How you know,
you know blackwater and the like the
most criminal mafia organization and
somehow the mercenaries. Yeah, they're
fucking mercenaries. Really. Holy Shit.
And did a couple tours. Yeah,
he was a marine sniper and then
want to make some more money after the
war. We want to make a lot of money.
I made a lot more money than he did
for the army. They did a couple tours,
opened up an MMA gym with it.
That's cool.
Kill some people.
Okay. No, that's good. I mean, I'm
just trying to be nice. I think,
I think anyone can go backwaters
a criminal but, but Erik Prince,
the guy who founded it actually did
think that he was ordained by God to like
fucking like kill Muslims. Like he thought
that he was carrying out a holy war.
So what did we do? We hired this
company, sent him over to fucking Iraq.
They massacre, God knows how many
people, but that's not the crazy part.
The crazy part that just came
out. Abby, the crazy word that
just came out is that basically we
went over to investigate them and um,
the State Department official went over
to Iraq right before the Nusser square
massacre,
which is when they just went out with
fucking machine guns and just like
slaughtered to 17, like fucking
women and children on the street.
Before that even happened,
the state of artificial went over to
Iraq and they're like, Yo, Yo, Yo,
this companies like out of fucking
control. You guys are just like,
sh like crashing into cars,
like running over people shooting
fucking birds in the sky and shit.
So they meet with the embassy
and they were like, what?
Like we need to, you know,
this contractor that we hired is
basically running our operation.
What did they do? The blackwater
guide. They're just said, we're,
I'm gonna fucking kill you. We're
going to kill you if you do anything.
And He fucking left terrified.
He told the embassy, he was like,
they're threatening to kill me.
And they're like, get out there.
Like you're threatening our
relationship now with blackwater.
Yeah.
And you fucking came back
beyond the law.
That's what's really crazy.
A lot of the things that were done
by blackwater, these war crimes,
they changed their name a couple of times
since then and now I believe they're
owned by the United Arab Emirates.
I think they hired prints to start
another organization because they were
worried about an Arab spring
event happening over there.
He's hot,
he's provided safe harbor and Abu Dhabi
and they something like Abu Dhabi in Abu
Dhabi and he did start, he did triple
canopy. That's what they just merged with.
So before it was blackwater,
then academy and then Z,
and then after the story came out,
all these other people
came out anonymously inside
blackwater x officials and
they're like, no, we like Erik.
Prince is like killing people.
Like Erik Prince has put out
hits on motherfuckers like,
we know this for sure and we're fucking
terrified to come out and actually put
our identities because we might die to
like that's how insane this student.
And he's just living
still making contracts
with the government.
The CIA just gave Blackwater
whatever the fuck they're called Dao.
Another contract earlier this year. Very
effective. Really good at their job.
I mean this day, people to shut
the fuck up about things. But boy,
those guys know how to shut people up.
Especially when you can do things
that are completely outside of the
jurisdiction. Right. Any laws?
Ours. Theirs, I mean that
word contractor. So cute.
Cause I was thinking of a polymer or a
guy was going to fucking get your roof.
That's a contractor. Like wait, will the,
those are contractors also have a
fucking sniper rifles. And like what?
That's a contractor. Oh,
okay. Like the, you know,
like when you heard that was one
of the things that kept like, um,
when that Fallujah thing happened
and they hung those contractors,
the United States contractors,
like I was like,
why are they killing construction worker?
They're killing contractors.
And then you realize, oh no, no,
they're killing Merce and Mary
were killing hired assassins.
Oh that's great.
That's,
that's like insurgent killed some
insurgents. What does that, oh,
people that are resisting,
that are in the,
they were born in this
place that we showed up with
tanks and they're resisting.
So they're insurgents, you know, oh,
they're not just people
that live there right now.
And then the other militants we
can, you know, throughout history,
people have had this incredible
ability to dehumanize with, with, uh,
terms.
You know,
you can just call them something and
then they become the enemy or categorize
them.
You know what Genghis Khan used to do?
Like anybody who didn't live in a tent
was, wasn't a bitch. You know, Tommy's,
that lived in these cities. Like they,
they just treated them like cattle. Right?
And that was why they were able to
justify killing millions and millions of
people.
And that's just one of the things that
people have figured out a way to do.
US versus them. We love it. We
love, I fucking hate windows users.
You know, I'm well Mac till I
die. I mean, it gets that dumb.
We literally Ford versus Chevy.
I saw a fucking Calvin and Hobbes thing.
Yeah.
Pissing on a Chevy logo.
Like he's standing on a Ford logo
and he's pissing on a Chevy logo.
If I had a fucking drone
with Hellfire missiles,
I might launch it at that fucking guy.
Did anyone who was the
fake balls on there? Yeah.
Well those could just be misguided.
No Shit.
If you gave me some of those fake balls
when I was 18 I might've put them on my
car. I was retarded, you know,
but the Calvin and Hobbes pissing on
a Ford logo, Jesus fucking Christ.
But there's people that like this
Chevy country, if you listen quiet,
you could hear a Ford rust like
fucking bumper stickers like that.
People love to be on God damn
teams your night blue or red.
We're,
we're really weird like that. And
what better way to do, you know,
to control the population to have these
like fake teams of political parties
that essentially there's total uniformity
when it comes to foreign policy and
the,
you know,
the militarization of like this country
and surveillance and all that shit.
But then you just have like these
minute differences in terms of like
integration or this and that.
Not saying that they're like known void.
Obviously there's like things that
are very good about the differences,
but on a big scale it's essentially you're
driving the fucking country in at the
ground.
Yeah. I think it's like what they're doing
is taking advantage of these ingrained
tribal sensibilities that have been with
us since we were in the small groups of
people that had worry about
other small groups of people.
Like we were just talking about this the
other day that this is like one of the
first times in human history where
if a boat load of people show up,
it's a good thing. You know? It
used to be when a boat showed up,
you're fucked.
Men are going to get off that boat.
They haven't seen pussy in a hundred
years. They have guns, they have no food,
they are rickets,
scurvy and shit and they're just going
to fucking shoot arrows at everybody and
rape everybody and take all your
food and light everything on fire.
I mean that's what people did and now
they're tourists like the, it's a,
it's a very weird time that we live in.
It's very in that sense
like that that's never happened before.
So I think there's a slight erosion
of this tribal attitude that you know,
people used to have and
it's because of access,
because we can go to places that
we couldn't go before much easier.
And it's also because of information
information and so it's when you have
enough of these kinds of conversations
and there's enough articles that are
written on the web,
there's enough conversations like real
legitimate objective conversation as
June. People that actually know what's
going on, where they go over the,
the facts on both sides and try to
come to some sort of a rational can QCC
unbiased conclusion.
It changes the culture.
I mean it's slowly but surely access
changes, the culture, access to areas,
changes and access to information
changes, right? We're a part of that.
It's all going on right now.
And that's why this younger generation,
these people that are growing up with
no idea of life without the Internet are
there, were completely repulsed by
these things that are happening.
But I think the people that if you
polled young people today in America and
Canada and places where
there's no conflict,
they don't have this ingrained sensibility
that's due to having family members
being murdered, you know, in front of
them and you ask them about nationalism.
I think their attitudes had been,
will be radically different than people
that live to a hundred years ago.
Totally. Yeah. I think
it's the modularization of
culture and it's a lot of,
it's the Internet.
I mean,
where else can you just see a guy getting
raped by a horse and Diana other than
the Internet? I mean, a hundred years
ago, he had never been able to see that.
But I think it's true.
I think nationalism,
I think people are realizing
how toxic it is. Um,
and the more that they travel on,
the more that they reach out online to
people across the world and they see that
we're all fucking human. We all bleed the
same, we all suffer loss the same way.
And there's only so much you can do
to indoctrinate someone to think that
someone else has a lesser
human being than you.
And I think that the more we learn about
what's going on and the more access we
have, that's going to really,
really a road. But fuck,
I mean the old guard is holding on,
they're clinging onto that man.
They're trying,
they're clinging on.
Well, ideology is the only thing that
glues everything in place to when you have
something like isis or you have like
this Palestinian versus Israel conflict.
The ideology of religion is one of the
few things that unites people in this
sort of very,
very rock solid position that just,
it's very hard to do with when you have,
uh,
an agnostic population,
it's very difficult to get them to just,
except that these people in Canada are
Douche bags and we'd go over there and
fucking take that pine trees. It just
doesn't make any sense. You know,
people would be like, what? We're
going to go to war with Canada. Right?
Can you imagine if for some
reason we found, you know,
this supply of diamonds or whatever the
fuck it is in Canada and all of a sudden,
you know, we started talking about
Canadian terrorism and like what?
Like we're going to go over to Canada.
Like, you know, people be like,
get the fuck out of here.
Look like, how could they be?
Well,
this is the first time
ever in my life I can recall,
um,
the public's opposition
to military action,
stopping military action like Syria.
Like when was the last time,
listen, put your hand
cup, your hand, your ear,
and listen to the news for anything
about fucking invading Syria. It,
it doesn't exist anymore.
That the, the, the conflict,
the idea of the dialogue of, of going
over there and military action. It's gone.
It's gone.
Because the overwhelming reaction to
that goofy fucking President Obama speech
left and right. People
are like, what? Yeah,
you're going to put our children at risk.
You're going to send children over
to fucking Syria for what? For?
What's going on over there?
Oh, someone use gas. Okay.
Why is that the red line?
Yeah.
What about the hundred and 50,000 people
who died at the hands of Assad and all
these rebels and all this
shit before that. It's like,
why do we have these arbitrary quote red
lines where that's when we need to go
and post military action? Like
what the fuck is that about? What?
I would love to have been in the room
when they talked to Obama and then making
that speech, right. And
that's when, you know, and,
and that's why I'm terrified
of Hillary Clinton, man.
Because if you read some articles about
who's really like, I mean, I think Obama,
once again, he's working and he's a
horrible precedent. And, um, but it,
Hillary's fucking crazy dude.
She's like as crazy as John Mccain,
they were like pushing him to get
into serious so hard. Any Ron. Yeah.
Hillary was like almost the one of the
most militant military hawks in his whole
national security team.
And Man,
it's going to be bad news if she gets in.
I blame bill.
She's probably a patient of when she
was younger, probably God damn hippie.
She looked like she was,
she got the big eyebrows fucking glasses
dealing with bill and it's fun and it
philandering she wants to
blow shit up now. Just anger.
That's how you create terrorists.
Lucky she doesn't have a Dick Shit.
Jesus Christ. She'd already be president
probably. Right, but what do you think?
Yeah, I mean it is
amazing and I think, um,
I don't know what the fucking think
about this Ukraine Shit, man. I, I mean,
were you following all that crazy
shit that happened with our tea? Oh,
what happened? They were trying to send
you over there, right? What happened?
What does that was, because I remember
reading that. I'm like, Oh shit,
they're trying to send Abby to Russia.
Wait,
I need to go to those thoughts
prompting again.
Oh, oh, there's Hillary
Clinton. Oh my God.
Look at that photo of Hilary
Clinton. First of all, do,
don't zoom in because if you do,
you miss the feet.
Look at those Goddamn Birkenstocks.
She might've had the original pair
of Birkenstocks and these pants,
she's wearing the striped pants that
look like a version of yoga pants in some
sort of a way.
They're very tight.
Who knows what kind of
material they're made out of.
But they're like multicolored
striped and they're all,
it's all pointing you towards her crotch
and some geometric pattern and she's
got glasses on.
What happened in the glasses?
She's still wear glasses kind
of sometimes. Contacts. Yeah,
I dunno that's her, that's her. When
she was young and bill and look at,
they were hippies.
He had a like a hipster beard and,
and she looked like a hippie.
Wow. And they were uh,
they were young students trying to
make their way in the world. Yeah.
Not Inhaling.
Hailing. Yeah. Fucking
liar. Either wearing,
inhaling cause they were putting it up
their asses so crazy. I heard they eat it.
If that's true. I they ate brownies. Did
you just make that up? No, I heard it.
Someone said that he didn't inhale.
That's why I say it.
It inhale cause they didn't
please he inhaled. Yeah.
Everybody that smokes pot inhales stop.
I tried it once.
I didn't like it.
If he didn't like it,
you're hanging around with the wrong
people. Come on dude, you tell me.
And all those chicks it he hooked up
with none of them smoked a joint before
they fuck you. Get out
of here. Look at her.
That's before she wanted to kill people.
If he's smart enough to be
the damn governor of Arkansas
is smart enough to know
that we'd enhance a sex guy's a freak
whipping his dick out all the time cause
she's hi Craig can do that.
They just like fucked some girl on the
desk in the Oval Office is like guess the
garden shed.
Just like super got to
do what mother fucker.
Imagine that stress being the God damn
president needs a blow off some steam
somehow caught the guy a little
slack. Hey that was the, hey I,
I don't, I don't give a fuck
about people's private lives.
They could have a million affairs.
I mean if you're a president,
that's the last thing that we
should be worrying about. Yeah,
I mean if anything it shows,
it shows you character
dirt.
And it also shows if you were in a
really high profile position of power,
it shows that you may be vulnerable
to like impulsive behavior,
which is kind of tricky because it's
like on one hand, yeah, I think that,
you know, especially if you're not in the
position to start wars and shit, like,
you know,
I'm not worried about what someone does.
The fucking head of Nabisco likes to
hire hookers. Like who's this shit?
Am I going to stop buying crackers?
You know what I mean?
It doesn't make any sense. But when
you're like in a political position,
when you're in a position of power,
this is a one time when I go maybe
Chicago look at their behavior because if
they're doing like really blatantly
ridiculous impulsive shit,
they might be like,
yeah,
they might be a sociopath,
but even more importantly they
might be out of control. Cause I,
I've known some people
that were completely out of
control and just so powerful.
They just think that they can
fucking do anything. Yeah. Yeah.
When you know you're
the head of a company,
that's not really an issue unless
there's some, some sort of our friends.
Yeah, it's a company that kills people.
That's, that's an issue. But you know,
if you're making tires or something,
that's probably not an issue.
But if you have the head of a
country that has the largest army,
the world has ever known,
not by like a small
margin, but by fuck Rome, okay,
we've got military bases in a
hundred countries, hundred bases,
Jesus fucking Christ like,
but Clinton,
Clinton is the way I described him,
he's the last great American Presidential
Dick's linger. They don't exist.
And Dick Slinger, yes, there's, they don't
exist anymore. You can't do that anymore.
There will be no more.
Every guy from now on that gets into
that role will be a Mitt Romney time.
There'll be super bland,
like just without any charisma whatsoever.
Cause guys with charisma,
they get laid right. You know,
like those JFK type guys
who can captivate a nation,
those guys are pussy chasers.
They can't,
he can't have a guy like that as a
president anymore. They don't exist.
Those charismatic leaders are like
that charisma, that ability to do that.
It's just too intoxicating to find
that rare one that doesn't act on those
abilities. Just this is
a different time, right?
We're going to have some
weird ass fucking presence.
I'm hoping that what it actually does
is it eliminates the position cause I
think the position of president is
the last great Alpha monkey position.
It's a dopey idea.
This idea that one person
as our figurehead is one
person that gets to make the
decisions and he can, the president
could veto it. What? One Guy?
300 the one guy for 300 million.
How's that fucking real?
How was that still real?
Right.
And then I love how people,
they blame him and then they also
excuse everything on him. They're like,
oh well he, you know, a president willing
to do some Motrin, but then they're like,
but a president should be
able to do this and that.
It's like way too much fucking power.
And then also the supreme court I think
really pisses me off though because
we're talking about a court that we have
nothing to do with. And they're like,
the end all be all arbitrators have a
lot of different shit and it's fucking
terrifying cause they're just fucking
elected until death. They're appointed.
They're basically like running this
fucking monarchy and it's, it's crazy.
It's disgusting.
There's a couple of fucking fascist
sitting on the supreme court and I don't
want them to have the decisions.
Scalia's it's sick. Fuck. He's crazy.
Alito Scalia still wants
sodomy to be illegal.
Yeah. That's how fucking warped
he is. He's actually said,
if people choose to have
men choose to marry men,
what's going to stop them
from having sex with,
you're like, I dunno where you're,
that's a sick fucking trajectory, dude.
What's going to stop them from marrying
pigeons? They're like, I'm sorry.
How are you Supreme Court judges?
Can Mary Pigeons All you want?
I don't give a fuck.
Um, I wanted to, yeah.
So what were you thinking when all this
fucking Rte should happen? I mean, I
was worried about you.
I was worried about you because you
were criticizing the Putin regime and,
well, here's the thing. Okay. And
I've had many people tweet at me, oh,
she's moved piece for fucking
right. Right, right, right, right.
They give you an incredible
amount of editorial leeway.
It's very obvious if
you watched the things,
me as your friend and knowing you and
having these long conversations with you
and then seeing you talk those,
that's fucking Abby Martin period.
And I don't know how much oversight
they have over the things that you say,
but when you're talking,
this is, you know,
this is your opinions on these things
and your opinions in in many situations,
critical of Russia and critical of Putin
and critical of this military regime
and their actions.
And you know,
there was this backlash where they were
saying they wanted to send you over,
where were they saying they were going
to send and what, what area was this?
What was going on?
So that was, that was like Russia did
this military incursion into Crimea,
right when all the Ukraine coup happen.
And then all of a sudden
the Russian military is like
making all these maneuvers
on the border of Ukraine.
And Crimea was basically the first
little territory right there.
It was fucking crazy. Cause I
hear, and this is what's so hard,
is like working at our t,
the world hates Russia right now.
Like the world fucking
hate trash right now.
And we're being told in the media
all day putins the, you know,
the biggest villain in the world.
We should all fucking hate Russia.
And then we're seeing like all of this
shit about the gay law and pussy riot and
all this stuff. So it's
really tough already to just
be working there, you know,
already. And it's even
tougher to know what the fuck.
The truth is when we already know
how biased the mainstream media is,
especially the way that they're
covering Israel, Palestine.
So when they're all telling us one thing,
but then all I'm getting is actual
like Russian sources. I'm like,
I don't fucking believe anything
that I'm seeing. Are you getting
like an agenda?
Oh No, I have total editorial freedom.
Here's the thing, rt Russia today,
you know it in the name.
It's literally the name of what the
biases it was created to put the Russian
perspective out in the world.
Um,
of course it's going to be
fucking biased toward Russia.
You wind up working for Russia today.
That's a very strange condition for
someone as opinionated as you it is.
I was actually covering a occupy
Oakland and Artie was the only media
organization like covering
the protest movement.
And so I kept seeing this weird like
Russian channel out there and I was like,
I don't know what the,
why the fuck this is Russian
stations covering occupy was like,
but it's great and I'm so grateful to
have this platform that they're at least
covering what's going on.
And,
and I really think it's because of
our [inaudible] coverage and they were
nominated for an Emmy for it.
That it really,
like we were able to see all the videos
go viral and I think it forced the
mainstream media to at least pay a
little bit of attention to occupy.
But that's how I got involved.
I saw our tea all over the place
in terms of occupies shit and um,
they wanted me to come and have a show.
I mean they,
they like their whole thing is they offer
the perspectives that you don't see so
they can like have the very extreme
libertarian voice and then they have like
the socialist voice.
They have looked the anarchist voice
and it just breaking through all the
mainstream media bullshit.
But when you're looking at the bias,
of course they're going to have
a fucking pro Russian bias.
It's funded by the Russian government,
just like you have the Al Jazeera is
Qatar, the emir of Qatar funds Al Jazeera,
just like BBC is run by the British
fucking crown dude. All of these,
does that bother you working there?
Um, it bothers me when people tell me
that I'm a propagandists and that I'm a
mouthpiece for Putin because I've already
displayed multiple times that I will
risk my job to speak out against
Putin if I feel like I want to.
And I have to. And that's what ha well
that, that I've done it twice already.
One time I saw all this
military maneuvering and
Crimea and I made a statement
and of course the mainstream
media picked it up,
touted me as this anti Russian hero
just because they had no idea who I was.
They didn't know how fucking controversial
my show was and how I like criticize
the US empire all the time.
So they picked the statement up,
made me an overnight sensation and then
they quickly realize like I was way too
controversial to be lauded.
So they ended up calling me like a fucking
crazy conspiracy theorist, you know,
lunatic. But what was
really crazy about that, um,
and I want to talk about our and more,
but what was so fucking crazy is if
anyone has watched house of cards,
that's exactly how this shit
actually operates in DC.
Like I made the statement
and in this girl was wall,
which was my colleague and actually one
of my best friends in DC saw all the
attention that I was getting and she was
just like a newsreader, very generic,
never heard her voice, any opinions.
Two days after this happened,
I was getting all this
international precedents.
So she resigns live on air and is like,
I can't work for Putin. I'm a mat.
Like this is a horrible network and we're,
and you know I'm for the truth and I'm
like pro American and all the shit.
And then she got picked up
and loaded all this shit.
And then I found out that
there was actually this
think tank called the foreign
policy initiative. This is where it gets
fucking weird full of neoconservatives.
It's the same people who started
the Iraq war bill crystal,
you know all these motherfuckers
who basically force us into Iraq.
They are like the most militant neo-con
faction of the entire DC establishment.
They've resurrected into a new think tank
called the foreign policy initiative.
And I found out that Liz was like
essentially being used by these people.
These people probably reached out to
her and they just said like, look,
we're gonna like help you get this media
tour behind you because their whole
platform,
if you look at their mission statement,
they want a new cold war with Russia.
That's what the FPI is all about.
And then you saw Liz
working with these dudes,
like she was just this fucking idiot
pawn who was basically used by all these
dudes in this neo-con think tank to
spread their agenda and that and it just,
it was so fucking crazy.
And these people in this think tank are
the ones that went out on the media and
called me crazy. They were
like, Abby's a false flag.
Putin had Abby do this to make our t
look like it's a legitimate news station.
Like they let journalists have
editorial freedom. They're like,
Liz is the real hero because she quit
and she like hates Russia and like we
should all pay attention to her. And
I was like, this is fucking crazy.
This is all like been manufactured.
And that's why I was like,
this is absolutely insane.
And I just saw this media machine
spinning and I was like the,
I was like being victimized by the
media machine that I critique every day.
That's fast.
That's fascinating to watch.
Propaganda disseminate, isn't it? Yeah.
Fascinating.
Seeds and water and grows and,
and then they,
they catch it and run with,
it was unreal. Men. Um, so
you're a Putin mouthpiece.
That's what we've gotten out of this.
But it was hilarious cause I woke up
the next morning after making that
statement and I woke up to a
press release saying we don't,
we don't push our journalists and to
saying what they need to say and like,
you know, but that's why we're shipping
Abby to Crimea. And I was like, pardon me,
fucking going to cry me as a fucking war
zone. Yeah. What did they say to you?
What was the actual conversation with you?
Because I remember they said someone had
said we want to send her there so she
can see it on the ground and see
what the situation actually is.
What was their contention where they were
saying that there was something wrong
with your perception of it?
Here's the problem and I've learned a
lot more about Crimea since I still stand
by everything I said.
But Russians have a very strong allegiance
with Crimea because Ukraine is like
half Russian speakers.
Ukraine.
I know like a lot of Ukrainians that I
know are literally identify with Russia,
like they speak Russian and they
don't speak Ukrainian and shit.
So Crimea to them was actually like,
they were scared and they did reach
out and they wanted help. Not, I'm,
I'm not justifying the military action
whatsoever and I think it was really
wrong to have these maneuvers right on
the heels of the school they worried
about with Crimea.
Um,
they were worried about the new interim
government and how there's just like a
lot of lawlessness,
lawlessness.
There's like all this shit going down
and I guess they reached out and wanted
this referendum. I don't know if it was
a fair referendum. I don't fucking know.
I'm not over there,
but my boss and I think the boss of
the whole RTI operation really didn't
understand what the fuck I was doing.
They were like,
I don't fucking get what you're talking
about. They're like, we're rushing.
You don't know what the
hell you're talking about.
You need to go over there
and check it out. To me,
I felt like it was a very Russian front
dish, punitive like threat, like, oh,
we're going to ship you there, see you
learn for yourself. And I was like,
what in the Holy Hell? Like obviously I'm
not going to go. And I told him, I said,
look,
I'll go if you give me like weeks that I
can prepare for war training and making
my contacts in Kiev and shit. I was
like, I would definitely consider going,
but I'm not just going to go there
tomorrow. Like what was the conversation?
They pull you into the office and we
want to talk to you about so much shit on
TV and uh,
we want to send you over to a war zone.
So I woke up and to this press
release without even being asked.
So I go into work knowing, and my boss
calls me and he's like, Hey, I'd be,
we need to talk to is like, I have like,
uh, he was like, he was like, we want to,
he's like, I have a really
great offer for you. I'm like,
I'm going to send me to Crimea.
Shit me there. I was like,
is that the offer because I'm not going.
And I was like,
I woke up to already saying that I was
so maybe you guys gotta get your shit
together and like fix these narratives
before you tell the world that I'm being
shipped there. So we worried about
being fired. Will you ready to walk?
I was ready to walk at that point and
I was just trying to see what they were
going to do. But I think I went into
my boss's office and I was like, look,
this is actually the best thing that's
ever happened to our tea. I was like,
let me say what I want to say because
people call this network of Putin
mouthpiece and I was like,
and you know for good reason because
it does pair it the Russian line.
I was like, but if you let me go out
there and fucking criticize Russia,
that's good. That's good. And I was like,
even Fox News has diverse opinions on,
they had Alan Colmes even though he was
like, oh pussy, you know what I mean?
But at least they had that space where
they could be like, we, you know,
we have liberals on sometimes it's
like you need that if you want to be
legitimate. And so I was like, fucking
run with it. Let me do my thing.
And at the end of the day,
I give them inordinate credit for
fucking letting me stay and letting me be
there. And you know, I don't
know what's going to happen.
But you cannot say the same for a lot
of corporate media stations that fired
people for criticizing war,
which is even scarier to me because
those aren't even funded by the US
government.
Yeah. But they're, yeah,
they're all terrified of the
wrath of the u s government.
The access to stories you
access to interviews, you know,
whenever you see Obama sit down with
bill O'Reilly, cross leg it, you know,
they're sitting there
like to jump to them.
They're fucking their feet dangling over
your other needs. Like all casual or
bizarre. Strange. Really.
Incestual it's weird because you
know that there's certain things,
they're not allowed to say questions
and are not allowed to ask.
Like you don't get that job
unless it's your safe as fuck.
You're walking into a nerf to room.
You know,
and O'Reilly can pretend to play hardball,
but it's going to be about economics
where Obama care or something like
we knew it was going to be about Ben
Gazi, IRS and Obamacare. Like he probably,
they probably already agreed to the terms.
It was all pre taped, all that shit.
We torture some folks
torture,
but I went after this whole thing happens.
I was like,
I went on Piers Morgan and Piers Morgan.
What a Dick Wad that guy.
That was hilarious because he had no idea.
Like he just thought that I'd go on there
and just talk all this shit about like
throwing my network under the best,
throw all my work that I'd done
there under the bus and just be like,
so you know you're working for this
overt propaganda machine. I was like,
no different than you bro.
Like no different than you.
It was like fucking look at
what you guys have been doing.
You guys have been warm on.
Green us.
He's a fool.
It's unbelievable.
He's a very strange fool because I find
it incredibly odd that they gave that
guy that job after his whole scandal
with, Oh I know the phone, tapping,
standing peep of victims phones.
And then did you ever see Chelsea
Handler manhandle him? She handled him.
That was really awkward. She
destroyed him. It was hilarious.
Oh she seems so irritating. I don't even
want to fucking be here right now. Rich.
Fuck. She doesn't give a shit.
She's a comic and a drunk and uh,
has it all out on the table.
She gives zero fucks,
you know.
So Pierce Morgan,
not paying attention to her and not even
talking to her and in between takes and
going over his notes and stuff.
Tex Winter Shit.
Yeah,
but I think self censorship is probably
the biggest issue that you see on media.
And this is what the point that I
was trying to make is that I'm like,
the only thing that I self censor about
is Russia because it's funded by fucking
restaurant.
The money comes from everywhere.
Even if you're looking at Pierre Omidyar,
there's a lot of fucking dirty
money that's going into that.
Like a lot of neo liberal fucked
up policies that he's done.
It's like no matter what,
if you want the platform,
unless you're Joe Rogan and
have the Joe Rogan experience,
the money's coming from somewhere.
Fucking shady man.
Do the Abby Martin experience.
I think I might, man. I mean
I think I might at some point,
but it's just like might have to, you
know what I mean? I mean if shit gets,
if shit keeps going
spiraling out of control,
I don't know how much longer I can like
be at an organization with dirty money
and still not, you know, not
feel like a hypocrite and shit.
But it really does come from everywhere.
Whether you're looking at MSNBC, NBC, CNN,
and I think that the biggest problem is
that those have dozens if not hundreds
of conflicts of interest. At
least you know rts, Russia,
you're not going to get news about Russia
from our tea. That's pretty obvious.
But if I'm watching MSNBC,
how many dozens of corporate advertisers
am I not going to get the truth about
how much are they self censoring
about the US are about Israel.
You know what I mean?
And so that's where it gets really tricky
because even though it's much more of
a gray area,
and I'd rather know the bias and I'd
rather know exactly who is funding the
organization so I can maneuver
around that and get the truth.
It's working for any company that
gets their money from various sources,
whether it's the Russian government,
whether it's corporations that sponsor
shows and want you to keep a non
confrontational,
non controversial stance on their network
because they have this agenda because
they're trying to promote as many
products as possible during the commercial
breaks.
I mean there's a whole bunch of reasons
because they want to negotiate good
guests. They want to make high
profile political guests feel at home.
So they have to censor opinions. Okay. Tax
Us. Yeah. Not Access baby. Yeah.
You know what we were saying before
about absolutism and that's what,
that's why I work for our tea.
Because if I was an absolute, it's,
that'd be living in the fucking jungle,
drinking rainwater.
I have an iPhone like criticized,
you know, PR the NSA a lot.
But look at fucking Facebook and apple,
they're all working with the NSA.
They're offering these backdoors.
I use these tools because I care more
about the truth and I'm giving up and I'm
compromising my moral values a little
bit because I'm not a fucking absolutest
because I believe in the bigger picture
that this is a platform that's going to
get the truth out to as
many people as possible.
That I'm using Facebook to spread the
message about this and that. And I,
I value that more than I do like cutting
off all social media because I believe
in privacy to the absolute extreme.
So I guess there's a lot of compromises
that you make living in this society
that we live in. And you
know, it's just tough.
You mentioned commercials,
Dude, pharmaceutical industry.
The U S is only one of two countries
in the entire world that allows direct
to consumer advertising about
pharmaceuticals and guess
who's fucking preventing
weed legalization than us?
Yeah, partnership for drug free America.
What is hilarious? Unbelievable.
They are funded by pharmaceutical
companies, drugs fund,
anti-drug commercials, kid, kid group Shit
like kids for a drug free America.
You're like you're pedaling but yet
you're giving Adderall a two year olds.
Well they used to take my
alcohol companies. They stopped.
Now it's just pharmaceuticals.
It's fucking real partnership
for a drug free America. Yeah.
I had a joke that it was just like hookers
doing commercials against strippers.
That's
drug free America.
Having commercials against weed,
pharmaceutical drugs kill a lot
of fucking people. We'd kill zero.
Like the idea behind it is so hilarious.
It's just gross.
It's gross and more transparent now
than ever before. And that's why,
you know you're not seeing that
talking dog commercial anymore.
It's really hard to push those things.
It was just a few years ago.
You know Lindsey,
I wish you wouldn't smoke weed.
Not the same and you smoke it
and wish you were on Ahcccs
so you just
take some fucking,
take some Adderall, get shit done.
Become a part of the workforce.
Lindsey worker,
fucking Adderall, man.
That shit's everywhere.
I know so many people that are on that
now. It's my God and really confusing.
It's like you become some hyper
vigilant corporate entities,
some mass producing consumer.
This,
this person that can work 16 hours a day,
hardcore and you just taxing and red
lining your system all day saying,
yeah, I know it dude's got
a serious problem with it.
You can, you can't get off.
And He fucking loves
it. Yum. Yum. Yum. Cha
10,000 kids right now.
Think about how many fucking kids,
two to three years old are on Adderall.
Oh yeah.
Is What are you first scribing to
fucking babies? Babies being a baby.
I'm tired of it.
I can't deal with the doctor.
Well, I had a next door neighbor did.
There's nothing wrong with their kid.
They got their kid on Ritalin or
something. One of those things.
PROZAC riddling something, some sort of
uh, uh, control the fucking kid drug.
And it was really bizarre, bizarre to
see this little kid become like a Zombie,
you know, just like dead, dead eyes
wandering around. I mean, they,
these people were such shitty neighbors.
They had a dog that was just so wild.
They had a weird fence,
like the kind of had a fence,
but any dog could go over there.
Like they had a fence,
it was connected to a hill so the dog
could just go up the hill and over the
fence. And I was like, Bro,
you got to put a real fucking,
like their dog would growl at me and shit.
And I told him that his dog growled at
me and he made up some crazy story about
my dog getting out and like,
does dog tried to attack him?
He grabbed him by his neck and he was
like, this fucking fat out of shape.
Dumpy dude.
I'm like,
you grabbed that dog's neck and kept
that doc from I'm talking is a big dog.
I'm like, that dog didn't try to,
plus my dog's not like aggressive,
like you're an asshole.
Right.
Just making up some story
because his dog is creepy.
He's dog would like rally
people and Shit. So, um,
it was the same guy that had
this kid that was just a kid.
It was just a kid and they just
didn't want to deal with it.
They didn't want to deal. Kids
need a God, they need a tension.
The mom was whacked out of her mind on
all sorts of fucking pills and the father
was just sort of absentee, worked all day,
12 hours a day, every day, never home.
And then when he was home the kid was too
much noise. So like put it up on pills,
get him on pills.
I was this crazy show.
My strange addiction where people eat
like fucking upholstery and thank,
I was watching one where their fucking
eat and taste like scotch tape. Third.
Do you think third,
third world countries and then that
problem or is it just this vacuous like
vapid like identity crisis
of American just being like,
what the fuck is life all about?
I don't know.
I mean I'm generalizing American culture
maybe way too much, but I've always,
where's that come from? Well,
people are fucking soft, you know,
it's this life is a little bit too easy.
It's a little too easy to go to the
supermarket and get your food a little too
easy to drive in the Jack in
the box and get your food.
It's a little too easy to exist in
this weird world that is completely and
totally unnatural. This cubicle world,
this world of sitting in a desk all day,
it's just not natural and
we're fucked up. We're, we're,
we're all really screwed
up because of that,
because of this unnatural existence
that our bodies are not designed for,
our minds are not designed for. So people
get wacky, they started eating tape,
started chewing. I'm fucking
the upholstery and eat
and curtains and you know,
it's fucking strange.
I mean,
if you look at like a
perfect example is act.
It's all about access, right?
Because in Florida they have the,
it's better now, but they had a
real issue for a long time before,
um, before they put out that
documentary, the oxycontin express,
that was crazy.
Oh yeah.
Where they call centers or whatever that
they just fuck pain management centers.
What's the address there?
Everywhere on the address.
It's just like close your eyes and throw
a dart at the map of Florida and you'll
fucking hit one.
And they were one stop shops,
which is disturbing it up.
But what's more disturbing was
that they didn't have a database.
So you could go to a doctor Jamie over
here and get a prescription and then,
you know,
you could go down the street and go to
doctor Mike and get a prescription from
him, and then you can go down the street
further the doctor Michelle and get a
prescription from her and
there's no one stop you. There's,
there's no one to know what you've
done. They, there was nothing.
And so because of that,
there was this insane number of people
that were on oxycontins. Like I'll,
I'll, I'll pull up the data,
I'll pull up the actual,
but the number of prescriptions of people,
um,
of prescriptions that people
had oxycontin's in Florida
as opposed to the rest
of the world.
And it's also where all the
drug dealers go to buy it.
And then they just go to their
respective states and sell. Yeah.
It's fucking nuts.
Yeah. It was real. It was real nuts. It
was something like 90%. No Way. Yeah.
90% of the,
um,
of all of the prescriptions in
the country, we're in Florida.
Oh yeah. Well, Americans,
I mean we can assume more opiates than
any other country in the world. Um,
there's like some insane stat,
like 40% of Americans are on,
like at least I think it's
honestly like five pills or more.
And I'm, I mean, I might be exaggerating,
but remember all last time Joe,
we were talking about the
opium and Afghanistan. Yes.
Did you hear that? We are.
The NSA is tapping every single phone
call and storing it and recording it in
Afghanistan.
That convinced to me that sealed the deal,
that we're like running drugs from there.
I was like,
so you're telling me that all every single
audio phone call that's made is being
tapped in start by the NSA and we're
still allowing 90% of the world's heroin
from coming out of there.
That's even fucking crazier.
Well,
it is.
But see what people get confused about
when it comes to this idea of tapping
phones is that there's a person that's
monitoring Abby Martin is a person that's
monitoring me as a person that's
got amber lions number. No,
it's all just being stored.
And if you get arrested then,
then they're going to go through
your shit with a fine tooth comb.
They have all this data, but until you
get arrested, they're just, you know,
oh yeah, yeah, totally. It's
the retroactive prosecution.
It's the ability to frame a case about
you going back in your history and doing
all the shit. Like you can pick
one black man set. Exactly.
Implied blackmail is what it is.
It's like,
it keeps you on the up and up.
It keeps you from challenging
authority because if you do,
they know a lot of shit about you. Abby
Martin. I guess my point is that if you,
if we wanted to stop the opium trade,
it wouldn't be that hard.
Yeah. Probably wouldn't
be as hard. Yeah. Um,
but yeah, no, dude, when people
know that they're being watched,
we were talking about, you know, the
generation, the Internet generation,
the problem is that there's no semblance
of privacy with the generation growing
up next. Um, that's all gone.
And people react differently.
They act differently when they know that
there's a camera on them when I know
that they're being recorded.
And what does that going to do
for just independent thought?
And I just hope that we can. Um, I just,
I don't know what the fuck's
going to happen, man. It's just,
it's getting really crazy. Um, the
surveillance state is just really,
really out of control.
Well,
the only thing that's fascinating to
me is that it's starting to eat itself.
Yeah.
It's like it just came out
recently that the NSA was,
they were sort of using surveillance on
the Senate. Yeah. So it's like, yeah,
it's like you're there, they're
eating themselves like, and then the
was being investigate those,
investigating the CIA and that's how
they found the head of CIA was having an
affair is because they were,
they were all investigating each other.
It's like they're eating
themselves. Like they, they've,
they've gone to cannibalism.
This,
one of the things that many people are
not aware is that a lot of government
agencies don't like the other government
agencies write, write, write, write,
hilarious. You assholes. It's
supposed to be on team America.
And the fucking FBI and the CIA
have issues with each other.
They don't share information. They go
back and figure it fucking real problems.
You know, I, I think that ultimately the,
the evil and the,
the,
the sort of creepy behavior
that's involved in the
surveillance state will prove
to be its own undoing because
they're gonna investigate each other.
They're going to expose
each other's issues. They're
going to, you know, they're,
they're attacking each other. Like
there's this whole thing, I mean, the,
the fucking head of the CIA,
the number one spook in the country gets
investigated by the FBI and he loses
his gig because it turns out that
he's having an affair. I mean,
if that doesn't show you
how crazy this is and that,
that guy betray us who lost
his Gig was, you know, I mean,
your member during the Iraq war,
he was like,
he was like Jesus of the battlefield. He
was like the guy that everybody went to,
he was the,
he had an affair,
can take you down and not like
war Alaris with the crate.
Some crazy bitch who was
banging a lot of dudes.
She was like into fucking
high level military guys know.
And they were just her thing.
They were kind of like weird swingers'
when it comes to, you know, hired killers.
Very strange. It's very strange. Yeah.
That other leak about GCHQ which is
like the NSA counterpart in Britain,
they actually,
it came out that they're manipulating
poles and online traffic and essentially
like, you know the whole like whoever
controls the past controls the president.
Well these people mother fuckers are
controlling the present and the future
because if you're manipulating polls,
that right there can change the course
of like the political evolution of the
country. If you're like, oh well
90% of UK citizens agree with this,
what are you going to like say no?
And it's like you're just
fucking making this shit up.
Like you could just make
it up now button again.
Then that the information comes out that
that's what's going on and it makes it
sort of invalid. Like anybody gone, man,
I can't, I think kind of in a way it does,
you know, it's like look like the
more the information comes out,
the more the information gets
in the hands of the people,
the more that information becomes invalid.
I mean it's it or at least it becomes
a weapon that's used against him.
Like the betray situation,
like Patraeus is like he was teaching
at City College of New York and as he's
walking he has to walk and you're see it
any other war criminal and kids follow
him and scream war criminal at them
and you're like, whoa, this is crazy.
These guys didn't have any protection.
Like they jettisoned him.
They took this guy who was
like the head killer, right?
He's the head military guy.
The top dude who apparently like he
would take credit for stuff that other
people really deserve credit for.
There was a lot of dissent.
There's a a lot of what real
issue in the military community,
they had issues with this
guy. I don't, you know,
I don't know how much
of this is true or not,
but watching him walk down the street
while these kids are yelling war criminal,
they're holding up these signs and
they're saying, we'll be back tomorrow.
We'll be back every day you're teaching
and it's like, this is crazy. Who,
who fucking expected this? And he
can't do it. Let's see if we get pull,
pull that video because you'll find it.
It's fascinating.
It's fascinating because it's
like who would have ever expected,
how would he have ever expected that
a chick he was banging led to this?
What a weird world we live in.
Well,
you could be the head of a military
machine that's responsible for,
what was the w?
It's between x hundred thousand and a
million innocence died in Iraq right now.
Over a million 2007 pole. That
was a million back then. Yeah,
and I can't even imagine thinking
of a pile of a million bodies.
Good luck trying to wrap your head around
that, but watching this guy, here it is.
It's fun
walking
blood all over you.
That is really crazy.
Then we just probably
thought he could slink off.
They don't touch him now, his face,
but they never get in front of them.
They don't stop him.
Wow. He just keeps walking just
like, well, what's so weird, John,
you the guy who basically codified
torture is still working at Berkeley.
He's just still teacher. They're like,
I don't, it's fucking crazy. John, you,
he's the guy who actually wrote like
the torture justification in the bush,
like torture memos. Like he actually wrote
the Law to actually legalize torture,
not legalize it,
but codified it so that
it was essentially illegal.
Yeah.
And he's a fucking criminal man
and he's just working at Berkeley.
I love when people do that though. I mean,
Kissinger, what kills me is that the,
like the, the oldest motherfuckers like
Kissinger and Bush senior, it's like how,
and Chaney, it's like, God damn,
you guys have had all the luck that you
can go skydiving when you're like 99
years old and you're like a workman
like Bush senior. And it's like, well,
how are you? How are you? So lucky.
Oh God,
22 times more oxycodone.
Wow. Are prescribed in Florida
than anywhere else in the country.
And these pain centers are just still
operating. Like they're still operating,
but they've cut them back and this is,
gets really crazy. The, these poor
people that were hooked on this shit,
now they have to go illegal
because there's no options. It's,
it's become a serious issue for,
for people that live in Florida because
you essentially have like all these
people that are hooked and they're,
they're kind of collateral
damage. You know, this, this,
this like oxycontin express comes out,
everybody finds out about this issue and
the pharmaceutical companies are just
raking it in,
raking it in and they've made a
bunch of people addicted. They've,
they've create all these addicts by
giving them this access is insane. Access.
Like go, what's wrong
with you? My back hurts.
Here's a prescription growing in store
and they go right next door and they give
him pills and the the hardest pills
to kick on the planet. I mean,
within a couple of days,
these fucking things are deep in your
bones and you're fucked. I have a,
I have a relative fucking
guy, just lost everything. He,
he became a junkie.
I watched,
I watched him have a regular job and then
just become a lying piece of shit that
never works and just always on pills.
It's fucking legal heroin. That's
exactly what it is. It's, it's,
it's even crazier.
It's more concentrated.
Swallow. You don't have to shoot up. You
don't have to fucking get a, uh, a rope.
You don't have to get a needle.
You don't have to stick a needle
in your arm and find a vein.
You don't have to do any of that.
Just pop a pill, boom, suck on it.
And then you need it.
Unbelievable that we are living in a
country where we just still a class one
drug schedule one, sorry. Is it
just in the United States? Um,
response, the New York
Times wrote a, yeah, the,
the government had a response and
the government's response is fucking,
hi. It's so stupid. I'm
looking for it. Right.
Uh, Dave semen pulled it up. Uh,
if you look on my Twitter from
July 31st I retweeted it, but it's,
uh,
the response is so God damn
goofy marijuana use affects
the developing brain.
Okay, here's the problem. All right.
Their arguments are all about
children. Well, they're about marijuana
use amongst adults.
It had no bearing and the
conversation doesn't make any sense.
It's completely irrelevant. But their
first two points are about children.
Marijuana use affects the developing
brain substance use in school age children
has, I'll touch on mental effect on
their academic achievement. Yeah.
You wonder why. First of all, it's
substance use, which includes alcohol,
which is legal and includes oxycodones
which are legal include includes a lot of
shit where illegal. Yeah, a
lot. A lot of things. Acute.
Yeah. Students who received,
and this is on the fucking
federal government's website,
students who received earned D's or F's
were more likely to be current users off
a marijuana than those who earned a raise.
Yeah,
okay. Whatever those
they're, they're high and
right, right. What are
you trying to say hi?
Because they're not paying
attention and none of that
school for the most part sucks a fat
deck and it's probably one of the reasons
why their highest fucking
not paying attention. School,
you're trying to stick around kid into a
square hole and most kids don't like it.
And most kids that are creative,
anybody that thinks outside the box,
anybody that has any sort of aspirations
in any sort of alternative career
outside of the academic process of, you
know, getting a degree, getting a job,
getting a cubicle, following
this very rigid pattern. Yeah.
The people have a problem with it.
People have a problem with people telling
them what to do and they get D's or
F's. They, yeah, they're more likely to
be the kind of kids that'll get high.
That's why Finland has the best fucking
education system in the world because
they have like very personalized
education because they know everyone isn't
uniform. Robots that fit
into a perfect little thing,
perfect package that everything's
standardized and this and that.
And when we're talking about like the,
the vapid nature of,
of people who like take all these fucking
drugs to try to fill this void or eat
upholstery and tape and shit
and glue. I mean, you know,
when you're living in a culture that
tells you that working is the best,
like if you work hard, you
can get anything that you
want. And that's not just,
that's just fucking not true anymore,
man.
The American dream isn't
available for everyone.
It would never really was and
it just not possible anymore.
And I think people just still want to
hold on to this dying fucking dream.
And we work harder than almost every
other fucking industrialized nation.
We're the only country,
literally North Korea and Saudi Arabia
both offer this and we don't paid
maternity leave. We don't even offer
paid maternity leave. So what the fuck?
I mean, it just nuts. It's like,
I think that we just put work above all
else and we're just working ourselves to
death. And it's really not
what life is all about.
Like even if you wanted to work and get
money and really what are the chances of
you getting into your dream job where
it doesn't feel like you're working? Um,
so ultimately you're going to be fucking
miserable working your ass off just to
get the money sitting in traffic,
fucking coming home.
You can't even have time to fuck your
wife or like make dinner and you just,
it just like this horrible cycle of course
that they're going to be used. Shit,
of course you're going to abuse drugs
like there's no purpose because the
purpose that you've put as your God is
money and as much as we all love to buy
shit,
like at the end of the day,
that's not going to fill the void of what
the meaning of life is and why you're
here.
That's the real issue with
materialism as well.
There's a lot of times people resort
to materialism to sort of placate
themselves because they're so miserable
with their job that they're at least I'm
going to get a reward. I'm going
to buy that fucking Lexus. They're,
they're at least going to get themselves
a nice watch through at least going to
get themselves a big TV.
They're going to,
it's asking them to be at least make
me feel better for this fucking creepy
existence that I've sort of locked myself
into that I get to do till I'm 65 and
then what? Then what? Then fucking
watch my knees. Give out, watch my back,
give out, watch my body decay.
What are the options? I don't know.
I would say to anybody that's
listening to this that's confused.
If there's another thing
that you want to do,
please at least tried to do it.
Find a way other people have,
you know this,
this idea that you should worked
for a company in some thankless,
loveless position and just keep
doing it until the wheels fall off.
Don't have kids until you have to.
Okay,
don't fucking get a
mortgage until you have to.
Don't do it and we just don't do
it. When you're young, don't do it.
Don't lock yourself in to needing a
certain amount of money every month.
Don't do it until it's
mandatory until it's necessary.
You could find other paths.
People can find other paths being
you're not going to find it.
Paying attention to the fucking news.
You're not going to find a paying
attention to most school teachers.
You're not going to find it.
Paying attention to most of the standards
that people hear applied to human
beings.
That's why DC is so fucking weird because
you're, that's where you live, right?
Yeah. It's fucking creepy
man. The belly of the beast.
I'm getting out of there soon.
I told my boss, I was like,
there's no way I can be here for another
year. I don't know. Big Sur, big Sur,
go live in a cave,
no cell phone reception to the Care Act
Shit and just fucking move out there
isn't it? I'm serious dude. After like
I'm going to take a long break but,
but DC is so weird because everyone there,
it's just like Hollywood for ugly people.
You've heard that same but it's
fucking true because everyone,
there's a Predator and everyone there,
they look like a pudgy faced. Karl Rove,
baby faced will like doughboy and they're
all like these white dudes wearing
plaid and all they're doing is just
trying to find out how they can fuck you
over to try to get like, you
know, use you to do this.
And it just a super creepy predatory
place and it's full of a lot of soul as
people and they're all like,
they've all navigated their,
because they feel like they can streamline
their careers and just fucking over
humanity essentially.
I mean I know that they're obviously
going there more altruistic goals but it
just sad that they are bred to say like,
you know this,
this is all that matters is money and
power essentially in power just corrupts
the shit out of people and they
just lose sight of so much.
Like once you're in that bubble you
really see outside of it and it just all
this like minuscule shit that you think
that you're changing stuff and really
like in the grand scheme of things
you're just kind of perpetuating the same
system and I just think it's
bad. I just feel like I'm, yeah,
there's not really too many
radical voices out there.
I have learned a lot more about like the
incompetence of government now that I'm
living there though I feel like I've
changed my mind about some things because
I've seen how fucking stupid everyone
is and how like much in a bubble people
are. I'm like, okay, I at least I
understand why things are the way
you mean as far as like the ideas of
conspiracy theories as opposed to just
total income.
Yeah,
I feel the same way as more of paid
attention to more things and more. I go,
listen man, there are conspiracies
for sure. They have always existed.
They probably will until we have total
transparency as far as people's thoughts
and actions, which may be come
a lot sooner than we think,
but more likely than not,
there's this terrible and competence
and then there's people that are
capitalizing on events. Exactly.
Because people capitalize on events.
A lot of times people say, you got to
look who benefited from this happening.
Actually no, because anytime any tragic
event happens, people benefit from it.
So it doesn't mean they cause said tragic
event and that's where a lot of these
conspiracy theorists,
they make this really egregious error
in judgment because it's not that the
cause of the event and that's why they're
benefiting because they planned it out,
right? It's usually that shit
is just fucked from the get go.
Like nine 11 is a perfect example.
So many people have benefited from nine
11 and there's a lot of people that try
to directly correlate those people that
have benefited from nine 11 with having
planned out nine 11 with very
little evidence. But there's,
there's an old saying,
I forgot how it goes exactly,
but to paraphrase it is like the uh,
there's any tragedy that
is not capitalized on is he
is a waste and that this is
like a staple of governments that they,
they look at any,
any situation where things go wrong.
Like Oklahoma City. Perfect example.
When they blew up the federal building,
whoever did it,
whether it's Timothy Mcveigh,
whether it was a fucking Illuminati,
whoever blew up that building,
one of the things that happened was they
started changing the laws on, on the,
the ability to act against terrorism,
homegrown terrorism.
They used to use the term light.
What does it not light skinned terrorism.
There was a clean skinned, I forget what
the term that they started using. Yeah.
The idea of looking for a terrorist that
you know as like a white man sort of
looking for an arrow.
Oh the homegrown. Yeah. Yeah. Home grown.
But it was like the,
the,
I think the term is like literally clean
skin terrorist or something like that.
But they changed the law.
They changed the laws directly
because of the Oklahoma City bombings.
Um, I, well after the, after I like
got propelled in the mainstream,
they resurrected all the shit that I had
done about nine 11 cause I used to be
in the nine 11 truth movement and
they were like, you're fucking crazy.
Here you are on video. Six years ago
saying it was an inside job, this shit.
And I was like,
look,
I don't think it was an inside job as
a journalist that would be extremely
irresponsible to claim
that, you know, anything.
All I can do is point out things that I
feel are wrong with the official story.
I feel like there's a lot of things that
are wrong with what we've been told.
Does that mean that we know what happened?
We can go out there and declare it now.
Um,
and really at this point all we can do
is point out the people that benefited
the people that exploited it.
Um,
because it's just the fact
that you're just, you know,
you're just called a conspiracy.
There's,
it's this catch all phrase that you
can just use to shut down debate.
But I still have some
questions about nine 11.
I have a lot of questions about nine 11,
but I don't,
I don't go out there and
say it was an inside job.
But what specifically
do you have questions?
But I have questions
about the insider trading.
The fact that there were dozens and
dozens of warnings beyond just the initial
PDB given to Condoleezza Rice,
St bin Laden Determined to strike within
the u s there's like dozens and dozens
more directly to the top of the
intelligence. And the fact that they,
I don't blame that just on incompetence.
I think that someone turned a blind
eye at the very least and that respect.
And then we know that people bet that
the stocks would fail and they fucking
made a shit load of money on it.
Who were those people?
They never investigated it. So there's
just certain things like that that,
that make me, me raise
eyebrows, but you know,
do I go out and say building
seven and shit like no,
because I just think at this point all
we can do is point to the questions that
we have and point to how they've
used the event. But I think that in,
in terms of all these
school shootings and shit,
the problem with this movement
is that it started off,
I was drawn to it because I'm like I,
you know,
I like to question the narratives that
I'm given because I think that they lie
about a lot of shit and rewrite history,
but then it's turned into this kind of
conspiracy culture where there's like a
conspiracy like fucking ink.
It's like making money off everything
and you're capitalizing on if everyone
thinks everyone wants to be
this celebrity on Youtube,
making these fucking paranoid videos
about the Illuminati and every school
shootings controlled and a false
flag and I'm just like, this is just,
that makes me just never want to touch
that shit again because I'm just like,
you guys have actually ruined
just asking questions like, yes,
we should all ask questions.
But when you're just going out there with
an hours of every event saying it's a
false flag,
you're actually making people like
never wanting to question like the,
the origin of these things
and that's dangerous,
which is disinformation as agent's job.
Absolutely.
Information agent is someone who connects
some really credible ideas with some
wacky alien on the moon
fucking conspiracies that
are so ridiculous that it
makes the other stuff that it's
connected to seem ridiculous. Exactly.
Have you ever read the, the
debunking of all that, um,
the insider trading stuff? It's pretty
interesting. Now, what is the debunking?
Well, you can even go to Snopes. Snopes
has it. Um, here, I'll read it. Uh,
in the days just prior to the
of September 11th, um, uh, uh,
attacks large quantities of stock and
United and American Airlines were traded
by persons with knowledge of the
upcoming nine 11 attacks. Right?
That's what everybody parrots false.
Uh,
origins on 11 September,
2001 for planes are hijacked and
used in the attack on America.
American Airlines flight 11,
leaving Boston bound for Los
Angeles, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. Leaving
Newark bound for San Francisco.
Each of these planes was deliberately
class a crashed killing all on board too.
And to the World Trade Center towers,
one to the Pentagon. The operation, uh,
taken years to plan.
The perpetrators knew well in advance.
In the month prior to 11 September,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Um,
unusual trading activity involving
American United stock was noted by market
analysts who at the time had
no idea what to make of it.
Wildly unusual discrepancies to
put, uh, in the put and call ratio.
25 to a hundred times normal
were reportedly observed
in stock options of the
two airlines in one case,
Bloomberg Trade Book Economic, uh,
electronic trade trading system identified
option volume in ual apparent of
United Airlines on 16th of August,
2001 that was 36 times higher than usual.
Um,
but it was during the final few trading
days that the most unusual variances of
activity occurred.
Okay.
Highly publicized allegations of
insider trading of advanced nine 11.
Generally rest on reports of unusual pre
nine 11 trading activities in companies
whose stock plummeted after the attacks.
Some unusual trading did in fact occur,
but each such trade proved to have an
innocuous explanation. For example,
the volume of put options instruments
that pay off only when a stock drops in
price surge in the parent company of
the United Airlines of September six and
American Airlines of September 10th
highly suspicious trading on its face yet
further investigation has revealed that
the trading had no connection with nine
11 and a single us based institutional
investor with no conceivable ties to Al
Qaeda purchased 95% of the ual puts on
September six as a part of a trading
strategy that also included buying
115,000 shares of American Airlines Up
September 10th similar.
Similarly,
much of the seemingly suspicious trading
in American on September 10th was
traced to a specific us base
options trading newsletter
facts to its subscribers
on Sunday, September 9th which
recommended these trades,
the SCC and FAA and FBI aided by other
agencies and the securities industry
devoted enormous resources
to investigating this issue,
including securing the cooperation
of many foreign governments.
These investigators have found that
the apparently suspicious because the
consistently proved innocuous.
So what they're saying is that the same
company also bought a Shitload of shares.
What, what sources this, I know it's on
snaps, but what's the actual citation?
It's a good question.
Um,
because I had just read the CBS report
cause someone was asking me about this
and I wanted to like
refresh my memory and,
and I mean people to this days claim
that they still don't know. And,
and even the nine 11 commission said that
they didn't investigate who made money
off the attack because it was a
little practical significance.
So if that's explained, that's great. That
still doesn't explain how rum, like how,
you know, Rumsfeld and Ashcroft and
Willie Brown were told not to fly.
Like who the fuck told him not to fly in?
Why weren't our lives is,
how do I know that they
said they were told,
I heard really brown on the radio show
saying I was told not to fly Rumsfeld and
Silverstein who worked in the building
and he had breakfast every morning.
He just didn't show up. I mean I just
think that people did have for knowledge,
I absolutely do.
And also the whole funding operation.
We know that there was $100,000 wire
transferred to the lead hijacker from mock
mood on med, which was the head
of Pakistanian intelligence.
And why the fuck weren't,
wasn't that followed up like he was
having breakfast with condo like with the
White House the week of nine 11 so it's
like there's just things that I just
don't fucking get and I just feel
like it was thrown under the rug.
And the fact that Saudi Arabia basically
financed this whole operation with
Pakistan and we flew out all of bin
Laden's family. That to me is just like,
what the fuck is that? So even if
you don't believe anything else,
if you have no other questions,
the fact that we are still
tight with Saudi Arabia,
funding them allies with them and they
essentially like knew about the attacks
and help to finance these hijackers
is insane to me. That's insane.
Yeah. Well the war they is very weird
too. When you start, they did this,
they funded that work.
Who is they and who came from?
No, no, no. We know Bob Graham.
Look at fucking Senator Bob Graham's been
screaming about this on the floor for
the last 10 years saying they actually
do know that they were financed by the
Saudi Arabian government,
that the Saudi Arabian government knew
and they'd tell him services knew about
these hijackers, where they
were. And it just unbelievable.
And is it possible that our allegiance
to Saudi Arabia financially is greater
than the the desire for
justice that yeah, we, we,
we make so much money from Saudi
Arabia oil. Yeah. And that,
that's obviously probably the same
reason why I've been loans family and was
shipped out of the country.
There's just so much money involved.
Well, I guess it just sickens me because
if it really was the biggest deal in the
world where they can implement a domestic
police state and kill a million Iraqis
and continue out this giant war on terror
wire tapping the planet because of it,
the fact that they didn't
want to investigate Saudi
Arabia because like the oil
money or whatever, the fuck trumps
the justice that says it all.
It does. It certainly does. It certainly
says that there's creepy shit going on.
And that this has been the
way it's always been. I mean,
this is the way they've always
done business. There is a massive,
massive amount of money in oil,
right?
The oil money is so hard for
any of us to even we too,
when you're especially start talking
about these, all the guard families,
these families that have
insane amounts of money,
like more like they're not publicly traded
companies. They're not, they're not. Uh,
they're not, they don't have to pay
taxes because they own countries.
It's like the ideas that we have
of the richest men in the world,
they're not really entirely
accurate because already
with Warren Buffet and Bill
Gates and what about these
prince king gave that
nobody knows about it. Okay.
Oil, they own massive
amounts of money. I mean,
the amount of money that these kings
have and these princes and sheikhs,
what is anybody ever will accurately got
reading and how much money they have.
Everyone watched house of sod because it
gives a really good background on Saudi
Arabia. But basically it's like a hundred
year old like regime because they just
discovered oil and they rise to this,
this status.
And if you just look at Saudi Arabia is
relationship with the u s like we said,
it tells you everything you need to know
because of the utter hypocrisy in terms
of human rights standards.
I mean Saudi Arabia is fucking disgusting.
Zero rights for women.
They used to execute gay people.
I think they just imprison
them for life now.
So if we want to talk about Rachel's
gay law, that's fine as well. We should,
but for fuck's sake,
let's talk about Saudi Arabia as well.
What is up with Russia's
gay law though? What, what,
why are they so like
worried about gay people?
I think Russia, uh, you know,
we're talking about a country that Soviet
Union collapse what, like 30 years ago.
So they're just like,
I think they're going through a lot of
fucking weird transitions where they're
just kind of going through
this evolutionary process.
I'm not trying to defend them at all.
I think the gala is terrible. Um,
and they have a lot of horrible
crackdowns on press freedom as well. Um,
but I think it's just completely like
apples and oranges when you're looking at
Russia and you're like, how
come you aren't as fucking
free as us? It's like, well,
the Soviet Union collapsed 30 years ago.
Like they're weird place. Like, and yeah,
they're run by a bunch of oligarchs and
it's a lot of fucked up shit going on,
but I just don't understand the totally
agregious demonization of Russia when at
the same time, you know, all these
partnerships are so much crazier.
We got to keep our mouth shut about
oil from pretty simple. It is,
it's very simple. Go pee
again. Ting, ting, ting,
ting to slippery,
slimy.
And Abby Martin is the
bladder of a small boys fist.
Well, we've managed to piss off a lot of
groups today. I think we should be proud.
Everybody hates us now. The
Saudi Arabians, the Jews,
probably the Palestinians. Dennis
Prager, uh, who else we can just,
Hillary Clinton's probably mad at us.
Everyone's going to go to portray us
is pissed. Yeah, they're all good.
We'll go to go down the list.
We live in weird times. Weird,
weird time to do, um,
an internet show too,
because you don't have a boss.
Like you could never do this.
You can never have this kind of a show
and put it on television because if you
did try to record it, someone would
come along and they would, you know,
they would chop this out or hack that
out and you can't talk shit about them or
this or it's not,
it's not the way it goes anymore.
We live in a weird world.
This world is changing too.
It's getting weirder and weirder and I
wonder what it's going to be like 50 a
hundred years from now.
If you go back and I was looking at this
video of Chicago and it was a Chicago
at the turn of the 20th century,
from the 19th century to the 20th century.
He's like the early,
early days in Chicago.
And there's these people that are like
riding the horses down the street.
And um, I don't remember when
the first cars came about.
It was like the 18 hundreds right?
The late 18 hundreds they first had cars
so there was like a couple cars in the
streets in Chicago early
19 hundreds and this, uh,
you look at this place and you like,
you see this like very quaint existence.
These people live to
these early 20th century.
We're talking about the difference between
now and a hundred years from now as
opposed to a hundred years ago,
early 20th century Chicago,
there was this video of these
people riding fucking horses,
horse drawn carriages and shit. It's
so weird. There was a couple cars,
you know,
there were these weird goofy ass cars
go like five miles an hour run on steam
and shit. But the, the
difference between then and now,
it's just stunning.
That's why we don't need like DC,
like we don't need,
these representatives were
not on horseback anymore.
We don't have the fucking Pony Express.
Like we don't need these
weird representatives that
represent like 30,000 people
like going and voicing.
It's like the electoral college
is totally fucking irrelevant
bullshit. But do you think
that it should be? Like,
is it possible that when you see people
like Mitt Romney or you see people that
are Scientologists,
that people could be too easily
manipulated and that somehow or another,
this has to be filtered through
representatives that understand the law,
but at least we know that
these representatives who
are going to cast the vote
for their constituents, these people
are educated, these people are moral.
These people are,
have high standards and high moral fabric.
It's gross. The idea is gross
because it's very elitist.
But would you like if you lived
in Utah, okay. And I love you too,
I just got back. Would you allow the
popular vote to decide a lot of things?
If you knew that there was a giant
percentage of people that were in a weird
cult that had some strange,
strange rules,
but look at it, the popular vote
was replaced Electoral College,
then New York and California,
which is full of,
I think a lot more intelligent people,
um,
would have much more of a poll and you
just don't even see politicians giving a
fuck about those states because
it all comes back to the like,
they know that it's going to go
this way or that way and it's just,
it's disgusting.
But fly
over states are gigantic,
right? 300 million people,
three 50 whenever it is in the country.
How many of them are New York, Chicago,
San Francisco?
How
we know, right? La Is it a third?
Because the other two third dangerous
hoes fucking creepers,
there's a giant percentage that God,
guns and Ram,
well at least, okay. So at least Europe,
this two party dictatorships just
crushing us, man. Because when you know,
you have, you have money
in politics, which is like,
people spend half their time
if not more fundraising, right?
So how could we ever get these people
to really care about changing shit if
they're just trying to make money to
win the next election and the elections
here just discussing this dog and pony
show, it's like this fucking celebrity.
They spent $1 billion last time.
You know, if you look at Europe,
you can argue about the parliamentary
system because of course there's fascist
parties that get in and that's not good.
But at least they have the avenues for
other voices other than like two parties.
And I think that it's just really
dangerous to have this system.
There was an interesting story in
the Guardian a couple of weeks ago,
um, that was, uh, it was the rise
of data and the death of politics.
And the idea was that tech pioneers in
the u s are advocating a new database
approach to governance,
algorithmic regulation.
But if technology provides the
answers to society's problems,
what happens to governments?
And this idea was sort of their
sort of extrapolating on that,
that we're, we don't need
these representatives anymore.
They're, they're their,
this,
their legacy.
They're this weird system that was in
place when you had to fucking attach a
note to a pigeon and send
that motherfucker lose to
get the word out. You know,
we don't need that anymore.
You could directly through your phone,
you could directly cast your opinion
on whatever it may be. You know,
and if we still have a
representative system, you could,
you could make the argument
that that's suppressive,
that's suppressive of the individual's
right to choose for themselves
and then Gchq couldn't. But at
the polls she's checking. But I,
but I think decentralization is really,
I think it's really key.
And with technology you see things like
bitcoin working outside the system.
I think that we can,
if we can maintain that neutrality,
if the FCC wants to implement that
and be fucking for the people for once
instead of telecom
whores, yeah. Then we can,
we can really create some sort of
decentralization online and try to create
other avenues outside the system.
Um,
it's just a dangerous world
because as you're saying,
the more information that we have,
the less relevant these like authority
and establishment systems will be.
But at the same time it can almost trap
ourselves in a box like the algorithms
online. It can cater your own
biases toward you, where you,
all of your Google search results
are catered toward your bias and your
preferential like you know,
searching habits and stuff.
So it's like what information,
the information that you're seeking
might be different than the information
she's seeking and that's not good
to a free and open society too.
Yeah, that is weird, right?
It's confirmation bias that comes from
surrounding yourself with likeminded
people. Exactly. Get
re really weird groups.
You know like if you've
ever gone to like a,
I like to go to like very bizarre websites
and message boards and listened to
people just debate about things.
The people that are just never would
come in contact with in real life and you
know,
there's some right wing
Republican websites out there
that are so bizarre there.
They're so strange. It's like Whoa, Whoa,
Whoa, Whoa, whoa. You guys are serious.
Like there was a Sarah Pailin website
launch recently, you know about that.
She's got her own online TV channel,
which costs
Liz wall is going to get a job there.
Probably that's the only thing she
could probably do smart enough to do.
But I was reading the,
the,
the comments and it's
like there were trolls.
It's like they were like comedy trolls,
you know,
and then I realized like you look at
the guy's profile and you follow those
other comments and you go,
oh no, your real, oh my God,
you're a real person. You know, like,
you know God in capital letters
is looking out for America.
God blesses this fine land and people
like Sarah Pailin and true in all capital
Americans are,
you know what?
We need to get this country back on track.
Like there's a few shitheads that I
follow on Twitter just for comedy and,
but they're fucking serious. They're
legit. Like they really just want gum.
It's so true, man. Everyone
check out. Margaret Heffernan,
she has this awesome Ted talk about
willful blindness and she has a whole book
on like competition and the confirmation
bias and how her whole thing,
it sounds so simple, but the way she
explains it is just like so mind blowing.
And she's just like,
you need to interact with people who
don't think what you do. You need,
this is like a part of human progress.
Like you need to and it'll
like reaffirming, you'll learn.
You can't just surround yourself
with yes men your whole life.
You need to be challenged every day,
like look and,
and not necessarily surround yourself
with a fucking trolls who are telling you,
you know what Sarah Palin's fucking great.
But watching the video like that dude,
like the thing that we just watched
about Israel, like, like do that,
see it someone else's point
of exactly. Yeah. This is, uh,
one of the guys that I follow. What Abe,
whatever label we stick on ourselves,
the kingdom,
all caps of heaven is for
who pleases the father.
All caps in heaven. Wow.
I love this guy. Oh,
I read it some Dick was
not going to publicize
a little egg dickhead.
No, he's got to face,
he's just like some really
retarded a right wing dude. I love,
I love reading his stuff though. Cause
I just go, what? You're a real guy,
right dude? It's so, and
I, and I'm, you know,
I'm a victim of it too because it's like,
who the fuck wants to hang out with?
Like people who are, you know, they're
pro, you're going to be a fight. Yeah.
This guy's super pro Israel.
Barack Hussein,
pray for Israel.
Use The IRS to attack America.
This is what line low life
socialist communist anti
Israel and tie u s demagogue
does. If they think Obama's a
communist. Wow. They need to really, uh,
Lillo's communism. It's clearly
a socialist. Yeah. It's like,
have you seen Obamacare?
Obamacare is a disaster.
The website alone is cost a billion,
trillion dollars and it eats babies,
runs on babies.
Christian May be very uncritical thinker
if they think Obama's at remotely as
Socialists. Well, yeah, I
don't know, but this is crazy,
crazy super religious folks.
I'm also back Israel because they believe
that Israel is where Jesus is coming
back. Right? Right. Like did you ever see
the vice piece where they send these, uh,
these folks, uh, who are like
super duper religious cuckoo heads.
They fucking make their pilgrimage.
They're Christians from America and
they make their pilgrimage to a,
to Israel and they follow
these people around and they,
they're reading scripture like out loud
on this fucking raft as they go, oh,
it's glorious.
It's glorious and all its shithead.
How have you seen an idiot abroad? Uh,
that's the, the rich. What's good, Ricky?
Gervais' second.
Hillary,
I haven't seen it makes everything
just looked like shit. Like a mix.
All the seven wonders of the world
just look terrible. Like this guy just
miserable. He goes and puts
them in the worst situations,
puts it in the worst hotels and shit.
Makes his life a living hell.
And he's just going around traveling
and complaining about everything.
It's fucking hysterical. It's
awesome. Ricky Gervais' is a genius,
but I want to ask you, have you
seen the vice special on Fukushima?
Yes. Oh my good God. This is
terrifying. I have a friend,
my friend ensign. Anyway, he goes
over there and he provides a few,
he's Japanese. He uh, well he's,
he was born in Hawaii but he's lived in
Japan for a long time and his Japanese
of, you know, his nationality, ethnicity
rather, but he's gone over there.
Um,
a bunch of times he goes over there and
it does a lot of like humanitarian aid
and he said it's really
strange because it goes,
cause you're over there and you feel
normal. He goes, you're feel fine,
but then you look at your radar tech
or your radioactive Geiger counter or
whatever and it's just
fucking off the charts.
Now you can only stay there for a certain
amount of time because you don't feel
anything.
Right.
Right about it. That's what's so fucked
up bro. It radiation. But I just, I mean,
even though I studied this shit every day,
I did not realize until you see it,
like until you see that that vice
special and you see the tanks,
how every day they're filling this whole
cool like reactor up with fresh water
draining the radioactive
water like multiple times a
day storing it and hundreds
of tanks that they're gonna run out
of room. All the tanks are leaking.
They're spilling like 30,000 gallons of
fucking radioactive water in the Pacific
Ocean every day. They have no idea
what the fuck they going to do.
And as the water's leaking out of these
tanks, they'd take the soil, dig it up,
and then store it in an empty lot.
Like they keep,
it's like there's no solution and
what are they going to fucking do now?
And what are they going to do? I don't
know. And then the Yakuza, they're high,
the Japanese government and Tepco or
hiring the Yakuza mafia there to help with
the fucking cleanup
because they owe them debt.
So all these like old Japanese men want
to help. They're like, we know how to,
how like we've worked on the
reactors or whole life. They're like,
let us go like we're old,
we can die.
And they're like wanting to sacrifice
themselves and instead they're hiring
mafia members from the Yakuza mob that
have no idea what the fuck 30 I'm doing.
It's a fucking nightmare, man. Real. Yeah.
What, what can they do? I mean,
I know that they have that idea to
dig this giant pit and then have it
surrounded with frozen cones and already
didn't work that already failed a
failure. Now the ice walls sound
like some Superman's. Yeah,
like a fucking prisoner interest of solid.
Well look, I mean look at Chernobyl.
They have this giant sarcophagus.
That's correct.
Jean. She was just telling me the
other day that um, you know, the,
the nuclear waste,
even with working reactors,
they just have to dig a pit and put
a fucking sign on it with a skull and
crossbones cause they're like,
whoa. In a million years,
even though the radioactive energy
will still be here, they're like,
at least the future civilization here
will know what a skull and cross bronzes
and they won't be able to dig up
this waste. You're like, holy fuck.
Why are we dealing with an energy
that we can't harness properly?
Like it's a miracle and it's magic,
but clearly we don't know what the fuck
we're doing with it. Well, you know
it. All it does is make steam. Yeah.
That's what's so crazy.
When you see what it really just is.
I thought that it did something like
may the electricity with the new clear
something,
a splitting atoms and it just goes right
through the wires and their housing it
and some giant fucking listening. They're
making steam. It's hot. It's hot as fuck.
Like couldn't they like uh,
do that in a better way?
Seems like a lot of ways to make steam.
Can you use boil water?
Can you guys fucking,
what do you assholes doing?
You guys are making some shit that you
can never shut off, which is really crazy.
Next to a fault line right next to the
ocean. It's like what can go wrong?
Well, they're all over
the place too, right?
The really bizarre thing is when you
drive down the California coast and you
realize that we are on a fault, right?
Like California moves all the time
and then you go on the way to San Diego.
This is fucking nuclear power plants.
That's right.
Design,
except very small difference.
It's GE as a general
electric design and they are,
we have 22 sister reactors here in the
u s that are almost identical to the
Fukushima ones.
Well,
the thing about the reactors, it's
super disturbing is people say, well,
it's clean, it's efficient.
It's very, it's very, you know,
as far as like the access to the
energy, it's very, very efficient.
But once those things go bad,
they're bad for forever.
So you have, as of now,
there's only two spots,
but those two spots are toast.
Chernobyl and Fukushima are fucking toast.
Those areas are fucked for
a hundred thousand years.
And then you have the storage of the
nuclear waste from all the other places
that are still operational.
And you have this spot in Nevada where
they have a fucking hole or Godzilla goes
to eat is radioactive energy. When he
lands here, I mean, what the fuck man?
Why this is only a hundred years less
than a hundred years of of splitting
atoms,
right?
Nuclear bomb 1945 and here we are
in 2014 less than a hundred years.
And you guys doing this shit and you
already have two spots that are broken.
You know,
if you could look at the future and you
look at all the potential spots to go
wrong, like if we, if we had a
hot map where you could, you know,
everything that's blue is a nuclear
reactor that's currently working and
functional and you have the two red spots
and then you look at all the potential
for red spots,
these blue ones to go bad like God,
we're going to fuck up a huge percentage
of the world with this power source.
And I don't know a better method,
but if I lived in California,
which I do and it never fucking
gets cloudy, which doesn't,
I would say maybe that's
solar thing is how you guys,
well, let's just try it. I mean,
the thing is it's not working.
I think that we really do need to
shut down. I'll reactors. I know I've,
I've had someone on my show to talk about
Thorin still there's a matter of the
waste, even though it's a much smaller
concentrated amount, it's still a problem.
And yes, maybe we can harness
it differently and more safely.
But at the end of the day,
like you said,
is it worth the risk to fucking have
this shit out there for a million years?
Like is it worth it when we do have
other sources? That's why Einstein,
when we did split the atom and Einstein
wrote this letter to the president and
he was like, Whoa, where
did that come from?
Right.
Um, but when, when they first
saw the nuclear bomb go off on,
on whatever the hell island it was that
they saw the first explosion, you know,
all they told them it was just to
wear little sunglasses out there.
There's that photo of all of them. They
like quoted Bhagavad Gita and they said,
we've become death. Like what have we
done? Like the guy who like Oppenheimer.
Yeah, yeah. It's so creepy
when Oppenheimer says it,
he quoted the Bhagavad Gita. He says,
I am become death destroyer of worlds.
It's a really creep pull it up because
it's, it's, it's a really bizarre,
because when you actually hear
it from Oppenheimer's voice,
when he talks about how he felt
and you see his face, the regret,
cause he was a part of this thing
and that's not even nuclear energy,
nuclear bomb, you know,
he decided, you know,
at that point in time that they'd
made tremendous, tremendous mistake.
And here we are,
2014 it's still our major source of
electricity in the United States from
America.
Everyone should check out
until the history of the
United States because in it I
learned that Reagan fucking Asshole,
he was actually approached by Gorbachev
to totally dismantle all of the nuclear
weapons. Like he was just like, look, it's
done. Let's fucking close it all down.
And Reagan was like, no, cause I'm
senile and I believe in Star Wars.
I think that we can create
this giant space program and Blah,
blah, blah. And he just like said no.
And I blame him. Dude.
He, he had the chance,
he had the golden ticket
and he gave up on it. Men,
I want to talk about conspiracies.
Have you ever looked in the star wars
scientists that have mysteriously been
murdered? No. Oh, good
Lord. That's a weird,
here's star wars scientists.
Yeah. If you do that, if you type that
in, first thing that pumps up his deaths,
conspiracy murdered. Whoa. Yeah. It's um,
who killed all the British star wards
scientists and there's a bunch of
different websites about it. Yeah.
Yeah. There's a, a real, it's a,
it's really fascinating how many
people died and the mysterious deaths,
uh, all 25 workers on the United
States Star Wars project were killed.
Uh, yeah, yeah, yeah. They
died in really weird ways.
He died in plane crashes
and all sorts of Shit. Yeah.
Did it just like the
sealed all 25 workers,
United States star wars projects
and the sting ray torpedo projects.
Um, although the United Kingdom's
Ministry of Defense still disputes,
these workers were connected
to the star wars project.
Most workers died either having finished
important projects or when they left
for other employers.
Several of those who died had routinely
expressed fears for their safety.
The manner of their death
was also very curious.
And despite open verdicts or verdicts
of suicide in the postmortems,
there were aspects to their desks that
made these verdicts seem highly unlikely.
One of the strangest desk
was that of Shinai Warren,
a personal assistant for the company
that was taken over by Ge. See Marconi,
Shari was found drowned in
18 inches of water, gagged,
a noose around her neck,
her feet balanced suicide and
her hands bound behind her back.
Wow.
Mark Wise and Arrow Sophomore,
a software engineer for the mod was found
dead with a plastic sack over his head
and several feet of clingfilm
wrapped around his head.
This was deemed an accident by the corner,
but it was exactly the same way as
Mark's colleague Richard Puig who met his
untimely. Uh, and several weeks earlier,
a Shard Sharif,
uh,
an experienced defense contractor was
found dead after placing a ligature around
his neck,
tying the other end around a tree
and driving off in his car with the
accelerator pedal jam down.
The police felt this was a
most unusual suicide method,
but still deemed it a suicide. Wow. Yeah.
He had last been seen in Bristol, um, uh,
a long way from his home looking into
guest house using cash and was witnessed
by a, with a large bag of money.
These details, although, uh,
known to the police were never
mentioned in his inquest.
There's a whole bunch of them. There's
a whole bunch of these. Very serious,
yeah. It's fucking fascinating, man.
It's fascinating how many of them died
because apparently star wars was total
horse shit, right? It was
never going to work. And,
and they knew it from the jump and all
the scientists that were connected to it
died.
So all these people that could have been
able to prove that these fuckers had
just embezzled all this
money and had used, you know,
their defense contracts
and spent all this cash,
all the people connected to it that
actually could prove the science behind it
or disprove the science
behind it are all dead.
That's insane. That's when, you know,
the CIO is up to some crazy shit.
It's amazing. Well, it's like, it
kind of makes sense, right? You know,
it's all that profit at the end of
the day, man. It really is. Yeah.
The story of birth of Champagne.
She was the maid of Jeb Bush or
Bush or Bush Senior's family,
or I forget who,
and she was found crushed
with an empty car that like,
you know,
someone had driven an empty car,
backed up into the garage and
crushed her to death and you're like,
what did she now clearly
shaken is killed. I mean, like,
no one in an empty car just doesn't
start and crush someone against the wall.
So crazy. Yeah. Between 1982 in 1986,
23 deaths of English scientists that
work in the star wars related projects.
Uh, professor Keith Boden
killed in an auto crash. Uh,
Jack Wolfson den died in a
glider accident. Earnest Broccoli
way suicide, Steph and drink
water suicide by strangulation.
Lieutenant Colonel Anthony,
godly missing declared dead George Frank
suicide by hanging Stephan Oak suicide
by hanging Johnathan Walsh suicide by
jumping from a building. Jonathan Britain,
suicide by carbon monoxide poisoning.
These are all within like
a year or two now. Sorry,
Sharif that guy that we talked about
placing the rope around his neck and
driving off. This is crazy.
It's just like the DC Madam,
that woman who came out and she was like,
oh,
I have all this shit that I'm
going to say, and she's like,
I'm never going to kill myself and I
can indict so many people and all of the
sudden she just killed her
staff whenever it was like, oh,
I guess she ended up killing herself.
You're like,
that's just a little bit strange.
Yeah.
DC madams those don't have a long life.
That's not a bad profession.
Yeah.
You didn't take the most
powerful murderers on the
planet who essentially have
all these methods and they have these
organizations that kill for forum.
I mean they have, whether it's
black water, whatever. I mean,
if there is a black water,
it's police.
If there's fucking cocacola
there's RC Cola. Okay.
There's some lower level
organizations of mercenaries.
This is not like there's black water.
You could only go to blackwater. No,
there's probably some dudes that are
really good at being a mercenary.
Do you know how to keep their
fucking mouth shut and they don't go?
Eric Prince and the
whole thing and you know,
do press conferences and changed
their name three or four times.
They might even have a fucking
name, right. Call Mike. You know,
Mike used to be a marine or a
green baret or whatever and he,
he likes making $50,000 a week better.
You know, so that guy works for you.
Gotta be a ton of those fucking people
out there. This outta be absolutely man.
So DC, Madam Madam, that bitch is
dead. She's fucking murdered bro.
And whatever happened to her, her,
all of her notes and all of her or
she committed suicide. That's the
official line of your question at,
you're an insane conspiracy. There's, well
you are and insane conspiracy theorist.
You have to admit, you have to be. If you
are conspiracy theorists, you're insane.
If you in, if you look into any
conspiracy, you're an insane conspiracy,
which is crazy because conspiracies
exist all the time on a local level.
People conspired to kill their kids,
like the kid in the car, tragically,
who the parents conspired to
like keep them in the car.
So if conspiracies happen between
parents to kill their children,
why is it so fucking crazy to imagine
that people at a higher level or
conspiring stuff? Because it's the whole,
they wouldn't be able to keep it secret,
blah, blah, blah. I mean, we
know that conspiracies exists.
Look at fucking Wall Street. What
does that and Ron, yeah, exactly.
Look at Gulf of Tonkin, right? They'll
get operation Northwoods. Exactly.
And look at the fucking,
the Bush administration was thinking
about doing a false flag event to get us
into why, oh my God, I
know. Oh my God. I know
what Dick Cheney said. Are they gonna
do like a sly a plane and like, yeah,
that was the operation Northwoods where
they were going to fly a plane and blow
it up in the sky and blame it on
the Cubans arm. Guan to our arm.
Cuban friendlies attack wanton him obey.
That was 62 and Kennedy went, what?
I mean, yeah, Nikki crazy. He
was like, no, no, no. Yeah.
That was signed by the
Joint Chiefs of Staff.
That wasn't just like some idle chatter
like they had signed off on that.
Talk about how stupid it is that we still
like hate Cuba and have this blockade
in CG on Cuba. What the fuck is Cuban
doing? US Cold War grudge, like just luck.
Cuba just live.
How's Tuba worse than Saudi
Arabia? I, there you go. Yeah,
and not well known.
They're super close and they make great
cigars and the women are really pretty
see in the great great boxers
and wrestlers and the right there
and I want to go like I did they,
I'm just saying this selfishly,
like I don't want to not
be able to go to Cuba.
I think it's just the
stupidest thing in the world.
Like we demonize this country
because we have this, you know,
communist grudge shit
against them and they've,
they're actually incorporating a lot
of different techniques. Like, um,
the Castro family is like,
look,
we admit that a lot of things have failed
in terms of like the business side and
we're like being creative.
We're opening ourselves up to like
some capitalist elements and I just,
I just like, I appreciate the fact
that they're learning from mistakes,
reinventing
the wheel. And I think that
we just have a lot to learn.
Like I just think closing ourselves
off from this tiny island nation is
disgusting and it's absurd. And
we'd still demonize them, you know?
Well there are definitely
fucked up though. I mean their,
their whole country and their system of
government and their system of forcing
occupation on people is pretty
fucking creepy. It's not great.
We should, but I mean, this
whole blockade, I just think
as a disgrace, you know?
Good for anybody. No,
no. And I think that,
who knows what it would be like if we
looked at the blockade. I don't know,
but it's just,
once again,
US and Israel are the only two countries
in the world to uphold the blockade.
It's like, just fucking let it go, man.
Well look what's going on with China who,
which was also an incredibly
communist country, you know,
and now they're really capitalists.
It's like really strange things or
have like a little element, you know?
I think the Cuba is a, it's a, it's a
very interesting place because, well,
you remember when Jay z went to Cuban,
he got in trouble and
in the media was like,
oh look it does he know that that
fucking che hated black people.
You're like, what are you talking
about? Like what is going on?
It was the weirdest and [inaudible] 64
or something when Che Guevara and he also
went over to Angola and fought like
the revolution in Africa. So it's like,
I don't know if that's really true,
but it's just so crazy.
He was the perfect guy though.
It'd be on a tee shirt.
He just looked like such a
great revolutionary. I know
people that wore a check.
We'll Vara tee shirt that
didn't know Jack Shit about,
remember there was that wave of Che
Guevara support that happened like,
like a decade ago or
so. It can, no one knew.
It was really what they were talking
about. Like you could look cool.
They have one, a cig,
we'll Vara tee shirt on.
People had Che Guevara Tattoos
and he's like, why? What,
what about Che Fucking Vive? A lot
of it. As soon as he stops, you know,
like the guy and he would have hated it.
I mean like the fact that he's become
this commercial figure would have been
like, he wouldn't fucking
hated that. You know,
it's just funny that he's become
this icon of like capitalism.
What's a perfect example of
these like surface inquiries?
Like people just go to look at it
like, oh that guy was bad ass. No,
no, like looking into it at all. No.
Trying to understand who he was or
knowing like deeply about who he was.
Yeah. This is like a baby. Cuba's
fucked up in a lot of ways. I,
it's a different way to live. You know,
like they don't have advertisements,
they have old cars.
It's kind of cool.
They have these restored old
cars driving around everywhere.
I'll give you see modern Cuba,
they have these 1950s cars.
They're driving around like these old
Chevy's and shit. It's really interesting.
I just want to go there and just learn
because they don't use pesticides and
shit cause it because of
how closed off they are.
And a lot of ways they've just adapted
in a lot of interesting ways that I just
think is, it's fascinating. I
think that we have, you know,
I know a lot of athletes that fleed Cuba,
so unfortunately I've seen the
worst side of it talking to
people that lived in Cuba
under the Castro regime,
people that tried to flee got caught,
you know,
were forced back and then escaped again.
I mean they,
these fucking people got on boats and
risk their lives had to be something
horribly wrong with the conditions they
were living in. Forced me to do that.
But I would like to know if
that's exacerbated by these
policies of not allowing
trade. Right. You know, and who knows,
like if trade was opened up trade and
also the influence of foreigners coming in
there and influencing them.
Culture. Tourists. Exactly. I mean,
I don't, you know, yeah. We're,
we're basically like forcing the
society to be closed off and who knows?
Like if they weren't,
you know,
if we allowed the fiber lines
to get the internet and that's,
and that's another
problem is we don't even,
we've like blocked off the fiber optic
like network from Cuba so it's like let
them have like do they
have the Internet at all?
They have like very limited
internet and I'd probably just,
I'm getting though the US maze there,
which by the way,
I'm going there next week I'm
going to go on Ebay and that weird,
you can go to Cuba, but only the part
of Cuba where it's a fucking much,
I was just like a fuck you to the
Cuban government just to be like,
we're going to build like
this torture base here. What?
Like how did that happen? It happened
obviously in the 60s is a long time ago.
They had that
based there. The military base have
been there for a long ass fucking time.
That was the operation Northwoods.
They were going to bomb Guantanamo
Bay and blame it on the Cubans. Yeah,
it is kind of fucked. Is that how
they're allowed to torture people?
We tortured some folks.
Is that how they're allowed to do that?
Because it's over there. I mean, could
you torture people on American soil?
That's a good question.
I think it's probably easier to absolve
themselves of responsibility from doing
it and keep it. That's why we have CIA
black sites and like port, like um,
you know, Poland and shit. So I think it's
just like, as long as it's out of sight,
out of mind.
But what's so crazy to me about the
getting of the thing is the Bo Bergdahl
Sangha, how they're like, we released the
five worst of the worst. It's like shit,
if you release the five
worst of the worst.
So what about the other 120 innocent
people that we already know are innocent?
Like why are they still in there?
If it was so easy to release
the five worst of the worst,
why won't they release those people?
Because they're worried that they're
going to go and say what happened to them?
Or is it because they would have to
admit that they were holding people that
weren't really, I mean, once they do
let them go and then they start talking,
then they'd have to admit that there's
probably a lot of other people that are
also like
for the bird Bowe Bergdahl thing.
I think that was Bo Bergdahl.
That was the dude who was like captured
by the Taliban and then they did a
prisoner swap five guys. Dude. Yeah.
So he came back and then they
gave those five dudes. Um,
and I think that really blew apart the
whole logic of keeping these people in
and Fontana my baby, because
before that Obama, you know,
he'd gotten office saying,
I'm going to close down get mountain.
Everyone blames the Republicans
for not letting him.
The truth is he could sign a national
security waiver and release every single
one today if you wanted to. And the fact
that he kept maintaining, well, you know,
we can't trust to take these people back
because Yemen can harbor terrorism and
like they can become terrorists and
then they can retaliate. And it's like,
well you trust Yemen to carry
out drone strikes there.
You're like working with the MNE
government and all these other fashions.
And that's where we, they
release these these dudes. Um,
and I just think that we need to fucking
get these people out of chemo cause
they're innocent.
And I would rather take the chance of
like having someone retaliate than to keep
an innocent person in prison for the
rest of their life with no charges.
And my whole thing is if they're so bad,
like those five, worst of the worst guys,
if they were so bad,
how can we couldn't find anything to
charge him with for 10 years? Like,
where was the charges? Where the
hell, what, what happened? You know.
Well I've seen some instances where
people were released and they talked about
what happened and how they got
arrested in the first place.
They just went to like organizations,
they went to meetings.
They wa they,
they listen to someone speak and then
they got locked into this idea of them
being a part of this organization.
Exactly. It's just like
a gang. I mean you,
I think that we have these romanticized
versions of what the Taliban and al
Qaeda is. It's just essentially
like a gang and that if you
are, you know, like, uh,
like a teenager and you're
like living in this area,
sometimes you are affiliated with a
gang because it's how you use fucking
survive or it's like how you want to
provide money for your family or you do
running errands because you don't
want to fucking get killed or beat up.
So all these loosely affiliated
people with like these organizations,
quote unquote terrorists organizations,
that was like, they were just swept up.
And those are the people who are just
killed now with drones and stuff.
And it just really,
it's this really bizarre
like interpretation of what
these entities really are
and how they operate. Um, it's just
like coming from Oakland and like the,
you know, gangs out in East Oakland. It's
like if you are affiliated with them,
do deserve to die.
Right.
And do you think that they can track
those guys that they released the five
people that they released, do you
think they had some sort of a method?
Like my dog is a thing they put
under skin, you know, and every,
if he gets like they take this thing
and if he gets picked up by the pound,
they run a scan on them and they go,
oh that's Joe's dog.
And then they can that be, they can call
me, you know, there's like a microchip.
I would imagine that you could have some
sort of a gps tracking device that you
could stick in someone's fucking scalp
and they wouldn't even know it's there or
wherever you know some,
some part of your body.
Yeah,
he went to Hell knows man.
I just think these people need to
be let out of prison. It's terrible
to let them out.
They're going to be mad.
They could cause havoc on us soil
so far. You know what, man,
so far there hasn't been
legitimate threat of terrorism.
If you want to include nine
11 and the Boston bombing,
other than that zero like
this report just came out,
we were just talking about this.
This report just came out that says
every single terrorist plot that's been
thwarted in the last 12 years has
been completely created by the FBI.
And this is like mainstream news,
Guardian Independent,
like all these people picked up on and
explain how that works cause it's really
fascinating how they do this.
So right now the FBI has 5,000 informants
working around the clock that are
getting paid probably like a hundred
gs with taxpayer money just so they can
facilitate,
create and then the word terrorist plots
to completely continue to legitimize
the domestic police
state and the war abroad.
So these people will go to mosques and
they'll pray really a morally on like
retarded people or like
mentally incompetent people
were extremely poor people.
And they'll say,
yo listen up 250 fucking gs and
they'll work with them for like a year.
Like we're talking bout like long con.
It was like a long ass cons.
Sometimes those, think about that
you're getting paid, you know,
an insane amount of money
to do this on our behalf,
to basically manipulate people who are
weak minded and to committing acts of
terrorism that would never have the
capabilities before and would never have
even thought of it before.
But they go into these mosques and they
go into all these organizations and
they're like, Yo, Yo, Yo, like
six months later they'll be
like, okay, well, you know,
we can talk about how fucked up
the u s government isn't stuff,
but let's do something about
it, you know? And then like,
they'll trust these people and then
over time if you're weak enough,
you'll be like, well fuck,
like, let's do it. You know?
I mean, it's just really sad.
And to me it's so sick because once they,
once they Thorte the plot and then they
can parade her on the media and be like,
Yo, we, uh, we foiled another
terrorist plot. Like, look,
we're still doing a good job guys,
but they don't tell you that
they created the terrorists.
And then of course they put in
prison for the rest of their life.
So it's another wasted life,
wasted capacity,
just put in fucking prison and
just keeping up this facade,
this charade that there's
terrorists everywhere and
that they want to blow us up
and it's all fucking bullshit, man.
We're more likely to get stung by a bee.
You were more lucky to get crushed by a
falling in furniture then we are dying
of a terrorist attack in this
country. We'll definitely, I mean,
I mean dead from it.
These things,
you're eight times more
likely to be killed by a cop,
then you are dead from a terrorist here.
So it's just like, it's totally insane.
And this report just blew the lid off it.
It was just unbelievable knowing
how much resources are going in.
And then you see this whole
terror watchlist thing were
1.5 million people have
been added to a terror watch
list and the last five years,
just the last five years
alone, 1.5 million. No,
cause I don't think I would've been
able to fly out here. So I think that,
but think about,
I mean,
you're telling me that 1.5 million people
and it's really making their lives a
living hell because you need flying
is like, you know what I mean?
And a lot of these people's families
are over and abroad and stuff.
And what came out on top of that no fly
list thing was that the FBI is actually
using the no fly list as a tool
to try to get more informants.
So they will go to like Muslim dudes and
be like, Yo, you're on this no fly list.
You want to get off it, become an
informant, turn against your community.
And because the people are saying no,
they're stuck on this list forever.
So now they're like using it as blackmail.
So there's like this huge class action
lawsuit trying to do like take these
people off the list and it's
a, it's a fucking mess, man. It's
a mess. It's a giant industry
story about the guy in Dallas who was
mentally and competent and they talked
into a, trying to detonate
a bomb that didn't exist.
It wasn't a bomb. It was never gonna blow
up. There was no bomb. Uh, they, they,
they gave him a fake bomb. It's like
they, they talked him into doing it,
financed the whole thing,
funded it coerced is poor fuck into
thinking he was going to blow the bomb.
And then when he tries to do it,
then they swoop in.
Gotcha. Right handed. Morocco,
there was even this one dude who worked
at the mosque that actually turned in
the informant to the FBI
because they were like,
there's some dude here like trying to
like talk a little shit. They're like,
oh that kind of backfired on us. We'll
don't worry about it. He's an American.
What? He's one of us cause you could
America just let him do his thing.
Let him do his job. He's there
to protect America. Okay.
It's insane.
It's very bizarre.
It's very bizarre that they think that
that's somehow or another law enforcement
or protecting and serving like
it's, this is, it's a loophole.
It's the DEA uses that loophole to,
there's a,
there was a rolling stones or a
story about a guy who was a dirty,
a DEA agent who would do
those sorts of things.
He would get someone who is
very vulnerable and slowly
but surely talk them into
getting him drugs and then you know,
connecting them with a much larger drug
dealer wasn't really a drug dealer and
like organizing and manipulating him
into some situation where he's going to
show him how to make a fuck load of money,
but there's no real drugs and so this
guy conspires with them and then they
fucking,
you're under arrest,
bye mate.
[inaudible] Dad.
I mean you, you, you give
him manipulating people.
It's totally complete and trap
and it's so wrong. It's so wrong.
And what's different than actual suicide
bomber recruiters in the Middle East
that we like condensed. They're
doing the same exact thing. Men,
while we're doing it for freedom,
we're under the constitution.
We have laws in this country that we
don't really pay attention to anymore.
I mean, how much of the
constitution is valid? Yeah.
After the NDA and you know,
then Patriot Act one and two,
what's left? We kind of
can do anything, right?
They can kind of just scoop you up and
lock you up and you don't have to have a
lawyer. You don't. You'd be,
they can do whatever they
now they're charging animal
rights activists with terrorism.
There were these two kids charged with
under the Animal Enterprise Terrorism Act
and you're like,
I don't know if releasing geese from up
farm could be construed as terrorism.
Well, fog was delicious. Fuck those kids.
These are comments that a geese try
quite my baby. They're assholes.
They're disgusting dinosaurs.
All birds are dinosaurs that made it.
That's what they are now.
They're actually sleep
thinking that a good percentage
of dinosaurs had feathers.
They're starting to find that now.
It's really fascinating. Whoa.
A lot of like raptors, like if they
think a lot of those fucking things had
feathers,
you know what?
I almost don't like that because now
it's going to make them look silly if we
like try to re reshape how
they really look for like, oh,
they don't look scary anymore.
They just like giant Dodo birds.
That's kind of funny. What kind
of makes sense? Yeah, we'll,
all the birds that we see today are
essentially dinosaurs that survived.
That's really what they are.
We don't really have any ramblers
and especially those, the,
those types of, you know the
birds with the clause, the talons,
those weird feet. Yeah.
Chicken. I have chickens.
I have 24 you have a little
tiny chickens. Yeah. Cool. Yeah.
I get fresh eggs from him every day, but
they're like, they're like pets. You know,
there's these weird things
that lay eggs that you eat.
Go grab and pick them up and they'll
chop their heads off and like rip their
body apart and eat the meat. No,
but I would, yeah. Shit got crazy.
24 of them that live off
those for a couple of weeks.
Horrible Food and 24 if shit got ugly,
I'd eat my dog.
I'm gonna be honest with you.
Kids are starving when you do.
I try to look for food,
but you want to see something gross.
Pull up aerial view factory farms.
I just want to show you this image that
looks like a festering Zombie wound and
it was like this photographer
that captured this image of,
and it's only in the US,
which is really like the craziest
of the factory farming. Um,
if you go on Google image searches, you
can find it. It looks like a giant green,
festering wound.
And it's really just like cows.
I Dunno, like millions of cows and
middle America and all of their waists,
like accumulating it. This lagoon.
It's fucking nuts. There's one of them.
And if you yeah, if you enlarge
that, has that, see all those dots.
Those are all cows to the
left. What? And those lots.
And that's all like the way,
that's all cow shit.
I don't know what it is, man. That's a
satellite image. I don't know what it is,
but east lagoon at Coronado feeders
in Texas, find the green one too.
I'm whoa. And unfortunately, um, there's
a lot of activists who, you know,
a lot of like animal rights activists
like my friend will potter look at that.
Isn't that nuts? Oh, what
is this? What does it say?
In a caption that it looks big.
That's huge waste lagoon in Texas.
We were wasting no something nuclear waste
site. No, no. It's just making it, yeah.
Yeah. It's comparing it to how gross
it looks, but there's all these,
there's these laws now called ag gag laws.
You can't even can't take photos of them.
If you see the Tortuga Charles. Yeah,
you get charged with terrorism. I'm
not aware of that. If you find that,
I mean look,
what they do is horrifying.
They chop their chickens beaks off when
they're little to keep them from pecking
each other because they're
in such close quarters.
They attack each other and it's a
disaster. The factory farming is horrific.
Terrible.
It's one of the reasons I've tried to
separate myself from that as much as
humanly possible. I, like I said, raise
my own chickens. Awesome. I hunt now.
I count of killed for
animals this year. Like dismantle
the whole thing too. That's cool.
You have a freezer full of meat and I eat
that and my goal is by the end of 2014
to only eat meat that I've hunted.
I'm like, Shit, where are you hunting?
I go on trips. Wow. Yeah.
That killed that deer. No Way.
The one that right there,
the hoods. Oh yeah. Crazy.
That's pretty bad ass. I mean,
if everyone knew where,
how food was made and where it came from,
I think that we'd eat a lot differently.
And I think people would view food
a lot differently. It just like,
we're so removed from the process of
food, which is really crazy. Yeah.
Well when you see it in the wild
and you shoot it yourself, I mean,
that's an animal.
That deer,
that was an animal that I got in Montana
that probably had never seen a person
before. Right. Because it was in the
badlands that was off the Missouri River.
The same place where Lewis
and Clark, uh, traveled. Wow.
Yeah. I mean, this is a very,
very remote place. There's no cell
phone reception. No nothing. Yeah,
it's pretty dope. It's cool animal
too. And it tasted delicious.
No hormones, no antibiotics, no
nitrates. And we're out of time. No,
Abby Martin, you're the shit. We did
three hours. Wow. There's so much.
We'll turn into a pumpkin. Someone want
to talk about, tell him anytime, anytime.
Like I said, I'll open this fucker up
at four o'clock in the morning for you.
Fuck you. Thanks so much.
Follow Abby on Twitter.
Check out at [inaudible]
dot org to Abby martin.org.
Watch her on our t until she escapes,
Informs Abby Martin Experience.
And uh, thanks to our sponsor,
thanks to tango to rogan.ting.com and
save yourself 25 bucks off of any ting
device. All right. We'll be back next
week with a, a lot of old podcasts.
So until then, go fuck yourselves, Huh?
Hm,
yeah.